ROLL. PORTANTINO I'M HERE
PORTANTINO HERE BATES BATES
HERE BRADFORD BRADFORD HERE
TORONTO TORONTO HERE HELL HELL
HERE JONES JONES HERE WHAT
CASKEY CASKEY HERE. OKAY SAY
WITH THAT JUST AS I DID THAT MY
PHONE RANG. SO THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN BY. THANKING MY VICE
CHAIRMAN IS BATES AND HER FOR
SCHOOL STAFF FOR ALL OF YOUR
COOPERATION THIS YEAR OBVIOUSLY
ARE. A COMPLETE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE STAFF HAS DONE AN
AWESOME JOB DON'T BLAME THEM IF
YOU DON'T LIKE THE OUTCOME. A
ME. BUT THEY'VE DONE GREAT WORK
AND SO THANK YOU ALL AND MY
FELLOW COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR.
GOING THROUGH ALL THIS THIS
YEAR WE HAD FOUR HUNDRED AND-
FORTY BILLS I THINK ON OUR
SUSPENSE FILE. WE'RE GONNA MOVE
QUICKLY THROUGH THE AGENDA
ALPHABETICAL BY ORDER. PLAY
CLOSE ATTENTION AS WE WILL ONLY
BE ADDRESSING MEASURES THAT
WILL BE UP FOR A VOTE THIS
MORNING. I'M GONNA HAVE FUN
BECAUSE THERE IS GOING TO BE
SOME SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCE
ANNOUNCEMENT BUT I'M NOT GONNA
DO IT TO THE END. AND THERE IS
GOING TO BE A LIST OF TWO YEAR
BILLS. WHICH I'M NOT GOING TO
DO TO THE END SEE ALL HAVE TO
STAY. AND PAY ATTENTION BECAUSE
OF I GIVE YOU ALL THAT IN THE
BEGINNING ALLOW RUN OUT THE
DOOR. IN SO WE'LL DO ALL THOSE
SPECIAL ANNOUNCEMENTS AT THE
END. WE ARE FOLLOWING THE
HEARING WILL BE POSTING THE
HEARING RESULTS. AND THE
ACTIONS TAKEN ON EACH MEASURE
ON THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
COMMITTEE WEBSITE I DO WANT TO
GIVE A SHOUT OUT. TO ALL THE
LOBBYISTS OUT THERE THERE'S A
YOUNG LADY IN THE SECOND ROW.
WHO OF ALL THE PEOPLE CAME TO
SEE ME ON ANY BILL THIS YEAR
WAS. CLEARLY THE BEST ADVOCATE
FOR A BILL SUMMARY STAND UP SO
WE CAN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY. YOU ALL HAVE A LOT TO
LEARN FROM HER BECAUSE SHE
CAPTIVATED MY ENTIRE OFFICE SO
WE JUST WANT TO GIVE HER A
SPECIAL SHOUT OUT. HI EVERYBODY
READY. OR SHOULD WE JUST NOT.
GONNA BE READY THESE ARE ALL MY
SPECIAL ANNOUNCEMENTS FOR THE
END SO WE'RE GOING TO GO RIGHT
TO BUSINESS AND AGAIN WE'RE
ONLY GONNA BE READING BILLS
WHERE THERE'S AN ACTION TAKEN
ON THEM IF THEY'RE NOT ON THE
TO YOUR LIST WHICH WILL BE READ
AT THE END OF THE HEARING.
THERE HELD ON SUSPENSE SO WE'RE
GONNA START WITH MS AYE YOUR
CURRY AB SEVEN FOUR FOUR
HEALTHCARE TELEHEALTH. THIS IS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION. NEED
A MOTION. I DON'T NEED A MOTION
ATTACHMENT NONE OF THEM SO I
DON'T NEED IT SO I DON'T NEED A
MOTION THE TO DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. AND WE WILL
CALL THE ROLL. PORTANTINO AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES
SNOW BRADFORD. BRADFORD I'D TO
RAZA. DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE
JONES. JONES I WAKE OWSKI MY
COUNTY I. THE ONE THAT BILL IS
OUT SIX TO ONE WE'RE MOVING ON
AB TEN THIRTY SIX ON ELECTIONS
AND THAT IS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS WITH THE MEMONS PER AUTHOR
DATA SUNSET AND MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
DRAWS IN TORONTO I HELL HILL
AYE JONES JONES NO WAY CASKEY
MY COUNTY I. THE BILL IS OUT
FIVE TWO ONE. MOVING ON TO AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO ON MASTER A
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING THAT IS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD I TO RAZA
DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES
JONES I WIECKOWSKI MY COUNTY I.
THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO. OR
MOVING ON AB FOURTEEN NINETY
FOUR ON MEDI CAL TELEHEALTH
THAT IS DO PASS WITH THE MEMONS
PER AUTHOR TO ELIMINATE THE
STAKEHOLDER WORKING GROUP AND
MAKE OTHER CLARIFYING CHANGES.
WE ARE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLE FROM A. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO AND THAT BILL WAS APPROVED
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE SEVEN TO
ZERO. PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO THE ROLL CALL
FROM A. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
IN THE BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
SEVEN TO ZERO. MOTION FOR ROLL
CALL AB SIX FIFTY EIGHT WATER
RIGHTS MANAGEMENT THAT IS A TO
PASS. AND WE ARE. SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLL CALL FROM MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO AN APPLE
WAS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF SEVEN. TO ZERO. MOVING
TO MS BAUER CON AND WE HAVE AB
EIGHT OH SEVEN WHICH IS TO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
STRIKE THE FUND TRANSFER
PROVISIONS. AMEND TO STRIKE THE
RENT AND SHELTER PROVISIONS
THAT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE. MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE FOR
PORTANTINO OUR TO PASS AS
AMENDED SORRY PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD I TO RAZA. TO
RAZA AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES. I
CASKEY CASKEY AYE. THE BILL IS
OUT OF SIX TO ZERO WE ON AB
ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE SUPERVISED
VISITATION THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED FOR AUTHOR TO
REPLACE THE TRAINING
REQUIREMENT WITH AN ONLINE
COURSE AND MAKE OTHER RELATED
CHANGES. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PERCEPTION THE ROLE FOR MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL
WAS APPROVED UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
SEVEN TO ZERO. MOVING AB
THIRTEEN FORTY FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AND WE'RE GONNA
DO A ROLL CALL. PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. VOTING BRADFORD BRADFORD
I TO RAZA TORONTO AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES JONES I'VE AYE
CASKEY MY CASKEY AYE. THE BILL
IS OUT SIXTY ZERO IT GOT SO
QUIET IN THE AIR. MOVING TO
MISTER BERMAN AB THREE OH TWO.
CORRECT OKAY AB THREE OH TWO
THAT BILL IS OUT WITH
AMENDMENTS TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION BY ONE YEAR
MODIFY THE OPT OUT PROVISIONS
AND EXEMPT FACILITIES NEAR
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS AND WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO. I PORTANTINO AYE
BATES NO BATES NO BRADFORD
BRADFORD I TO RAZA TORONTO AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES JONES NO
WAY CASKEY MAKOWSKI AYE. THE
BILL IS OUT FIVE TO TWO AB FIVE
TWENTY ONE UC FIREARM. VIOLENCE
PREVENTION TRAINING AND IS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE DRAWS IN TORONTO
AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES. JONES
NO WAY CASKEY MAKOWSKI AYE. THE
BILL HAS ON FIVE TO ONE. MOVING
ON TO AB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT ON
FORENSIC EXAMINATIONS THAT IS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION OR DO
PASSED MOTION WITH A MEMBERS
PROFIT THE STRIKE SPECIFIED
REQUIREMENTS INTO ALLOW STI
TESTING IF WARRANTED WE'RE
TESTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS SEVEN TO ZERO VOTE.
WILL BE ON THE AB SIX SO TO
DECEPTIVE RECORDINGS OF THE
MOTION IS TO PASS WITH THE
MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED A CHANGE
DEFINITIONS ELEMENTS OF THE
ACTION WILL CONDUCT AND WHAT A
HARM PLAINTIFF MAY RECOVER AND
RECEPTION THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THAT
BILLS APPROVED ANY UNANIMOUS
SEVEN. TO ZERO VOTE AB SIX TWO
THREE ELECTIONS PRINTING
REQUIREMENTSAND BALLOT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS RECEPTION THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL IS APPROVED
ANY. NATOMAS SEVEN TO ZERO VOTE.
TORONTO I HELD HILL AYE JONES.
JONES NO WAY CASKEY HI MY
COUNTY I.BILLS OUT FIVE TO ONE.
OUR FINAL MISTER BERMAN BILL IS
AB SIX SEVENTY ONE CALTRANS
TRUCK TUNING AND TECHNOLOGY
TESTING PILOT PERCEPTION TO THE
ROLL CALL FROM A. B. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO BILLS APPROVED SEVEN
TWO ZERO TWO FAST. TO DO PASSED
MOTION. MOVING TO MISTER
BIGELOW WE ARE AB FIVE TWENTY
FOUR IS A TO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS TO STRIKE DEL NORTE
COUNTY RECEPTION THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAY BE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
SEVEN TO ZERO. VOTE AB SEVEN
FIFTY NINE TRAFFIC SAFETY
PROTECTION MEASURES AND WORK
SOUNDS WERE GONNA THAT TO DO
PASS SUB TO THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAY BE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS SEVEN TO ZERO VOTE.
FOR MOVING RESTER BLOOM. MARIE.
REMOVING MR BLOOM. GONNA DO A.
B. FIVE NINETY EIGHT ON HEARING
AIDS FOR MINORS THAT BILL IS A
TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO ADD
A CO AUTHOR SO THAT BILL IS A
TO PASS AND WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL WAS APPROVED I MEAN ANIMUS
VOTE OF SEVEN TO ZERO MARIE STE
YOUNG PEOPLE ALL OVER THE STATE
ARE GOING TO THANK YOU FOR THIS
SHOW. THAT PHYLLIS OUT. SEVEN
ZERO. AB EIGHT EIGHT ONE IS
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS THAT
TO DO PASS. ORGANISED
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE THREE TO THAT BILL WAS
APPROVED ON A FIVE TO VOTE.
WITH MY- REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
VOTING NO. AB FIFTEEN ELEVEN
SANTA MONICA BAY RESTORATION
COMMISSION THAT SAID TO PASS
WITH A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM A. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE BILL IS. APPROVED BY
UNANIMOUS VOTE SEVEN TO ZERO.
APPROVED ON A FIVE TO VOTE WITH
MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES VOTING
NO. MOVING TO MISTER BONTA. AB
THIRTY TWO STATE PRISONS
PRIVATE FOR PROFIT THAT IS A TO
PASS WE'RE SUBSTANTIVE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE THREE OH TWO THE
BILL WAS APPROVED ON A FIVE TO
VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
AB THREE FOURTEEN PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELEASE TIME THAT IS
A TO PASS RECEPTION ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE THREE OH TO THE BILL
WAS APPROVED ON A FIVE TO VOTE
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW AB
EIGHT FORTY NINE ELECTION CITY
AND COUNTY REDISTRICTING. THAT
IS A TO PASS WITH THE MEMBERS
PER AUTHOR TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES FOR SUBS IN THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE THREE OH TO THE
BILL WAS APPROVED FIVE TO TWO
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW AB
ELEVEN NINETY ONE OAKLAND
WATERFRONT BALLPARK ACT. THAT
IS A TO PASS A SUBSTANTIVE ROLE
KAUFER MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THE BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS SEVEN TO ZERO VOTE AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE DATA THAT BILL IS
MOTION IS THE TO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO STRIKE
CERTAIN DATA ELEMENTS AMENDED
STRIKE SHORTER REPORTING PERIOD
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES SO
WE ARE GOING TO DO A ROLL CALL
ON A. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES VOTING BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE DRAWS IN. TORONTO AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES. JONES NO AYE
CASKEY HI MY COUNTY I. THE BILL
PASSES FIVE TO ONE. AB THIRTEEN
NINETY ONE ELECTIONS VOTER
LANGUAGE SAID IS A TO PASS FOR
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
REMOVE THE CRIME AND SAID VOTER
LANGUAGE PREFERENCES BE VISIBLE
ON A VOTER NOTIFICATION CARD IN
A SUBSTANTIVE ROLL CALL FROM A.
B. THIRTEEN. MOTION AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE THREE OH TO THE BILL WAS
APPROVED ON A FIVE TO VOTE WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW AB
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL TRANSPORTATION SERVICES
THAT IS A DO PASS AMENDED WITH
A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO CLARIFY
OPERATIVE PERIOD TO MAKE OTHER
RELATED CHANGES AND WE'RE GONNA
DO A ROLL CALL VOTE. PORTANTINO
AYE PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BRADFORD BRADFORD EITHER ALSO.
TORONTO AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES IOWA CASKEY MAKOWSKI AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT SIX ZERO.
MOVING TO MR PEROT DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS ENTERPRISES
THAT BILL HOURS TO DO PASS FOR
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHORED A
REVISED THE CONDITIONS FOR
SUBCONTRACTOR SUBSTITUTION
WE'RE GONNA SUB TO DO THE ROLL
CALL FROM MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THE BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS SEVEN TO ZERO. VOTE.
WILL BE TO MS BURKE AB TWENTY
THREE OFFICE OF SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATE WORKFORCE COORDINATION
THAT IS A DO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED ELIMINATE
THE ESTABLISH POSITION. AND
RECAST THE NEWLY CREATED UNIT
SUBSTANTIVE ROLE KAUFER MAY BE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL
WAS APPROVED IN THE UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF SEVEN TO ZERO. AB EIGHT
FIFTY TWO PEOPLE INSTRUCTION
UPDATE ACADEMIC CONTENT
STANDARDS THAT IS A D. PASS
RECEPTION THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL WAS APPROVED. SEVEN TWO
ZERO AB EIGHT NINETY ONE CITY
COUNTY SAFE PARKING PROGRAM SET
TO DO PASSED WITH A MAMMOTH FOR
AUTHOR TO GRANT LIMITED CIVIL
LIABILITY TO LOCAL ENTITIES
THAT ESTABLISH A PROGRAM. AND
ADD LEGISLATIVE FINDINGS. WERE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB. THREE OH. RECEPTION THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THREE OH
TOO AND THAT BILL WAS APPROVED
ON A FIVE TO VOTE WITH OUR
REPUBLICANS RUNNING. NOW MOVING
TO MISTER CALDERON AB TWO
ELEVEN PERSONAL INCOME TAX
DEDUCTION CALIFORNIA QUALIFIED
TUITION PROGRAM. THAT BILL IS A
TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR. TO ALLOW ACCOUNT
HOLDERS TO TRANSFER FUNDS
BETWEEN ACCOUNTS AS SPECIFIED
IN THE MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES.
WERE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FOR
MAY BE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL IS APPROVED ANY UNANIMOUS
SEVEN. TO ZERO VOTE AB THREE
FOUR FOUR A NEW BEGINNING
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM IS TO PASS.
AND WE'RE GONNA DO A ROLL CALL
AN AB THREE FOUR FOUR. AND YOU
KNOW I YOU KNOW I BATES ALL
RIGHT BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE DORADO. DORADO AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES. BY CASKEY
MAKOWSKI I. THE BILL IS OUT OF
SIX TO ZERO. SIX TWO ZERO AB
FIVE SIXTY SEVEN LONG CARE
INSURANCE IS A DO PASS AND
WE'RE GOING TO DO A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON AB FIVE SIXTY SEVEN
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BRADFORD BRADFORD I TO
RAZA DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE
JONES JONES NO WAY CASCADE HI
MY COUNTY I. THE BILL IS OUT
FIVE TO ONE AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
TO PASS AS AMENDED FOR AUTHOR
TO PROVIDE ALTERNATIVES IF DATA
CANNOT BE COLLECTED WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FROM
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS SEVEN TO ZERO. VOTE.
MOVIE TO MISS CARILLO AB FIVE
FIVE SIX IS A DO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO MAKE
MINOR TECHNICAL CHANGES. GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAY BE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL IS APPROVED ON UNANIMOUS
SEVEN TO ZERO VOTE SB SIX SEVEN
THREE FERRY TO PAY WAGES. THAT
IS A DO PASS WE ARE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FOR MAYBE
THREE OH TO THE BILL WAS
APPROVED ON A FIVE TO VOTE WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
ENROLLMENT DISCRIMINATION IT IS
A DO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS FOR
AUTHOR TO ALLOW A PERSON TO
PURSUE BOTH ADMINISTRATIVE AND
JUDICIAL OPTIONS SUCH AS THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THREE OH TO
THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A FIVE
TO VOTE. WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NOW AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT ADULT EDUCATION WORK
GROUP TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS
FOR AUTHORED A MODIFY.
COMPOSITION OF THE WORKGROUP
PERCEPTION ROLL CALL FOR MAY BE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL
WAS APPROVED. ON A UNANIMOUS
SEVEN TO ZERO VOTE. AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT. CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS RE ENTRY
PROGRAM. THAT IS A TO PASS FOR
THE MEMBERS TO MAKE CONTINGENT
UPON AND APPROPRIATIONS IN THE
BUDGET. SUBSTANCE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL IS APPROVED BY UNANIMOUS
SEVEN TO ZERO VOTE. AB SIXTEEN
NINETY FIVE HEALTH FACILITIES.
THAT IS A DO PASS AND WE'RE SUB
TO THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
THREE OH TWO. BILLS APPROVED ON
A FIVE TO. VOTE WITH NO
REPUBLICANS WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NOW SORRY. AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY OPR LAND USE GUIDELINES
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES IS A TO
PASS. OR SUBJECT IN THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO. BILLS. APPROVED ANY
ANONYMOUS VOTE OF SEVEN. TO
ZERO. MOVING TO MISS CERVANTES
AB ONE SIXTY FOUR FIREARMS THAT
IS A TO PASS AND WE ARE SUB TO
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO. BILLS
APPROVED SEVEN TO ZERO AB THREE
OH THREE SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATORS TRIAL AMENDS FOR
AUTHORED A STRIKE TO
REQUIREMENTS INCLUDE SPECIFIED
INFORMATION IN THE MINUTES. OF
THE PROCEEDINGS AND THAT IS A
STEPS TO ROLL CALL THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL WAS
APPROVED ON A SEVEN TO ZERO.
VOTE AB FOR SIXTY THREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAM. PERCEPTION
THE ROLE FROM AB THREE OH TO
THE BILL'S APPROVAL THE FIVE TO
VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING.
I'M SORRY AND YOU HAVE TO PASS
MOTIONS HE'S ME FIVE TO BUY AB
SIX THREE NINE WORK FORCE
IMPACTS OF A LOWER CARBON
ECONOMY. AMENDMENTS TO REQUIRE
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT TO DO
PASS FOR THE MEMBERS REQUIRE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD TO
PRESENT ANY INFORMATION REPORT
IN LIEU OF CHANGES TO THE A RP
SCOPING PLAN AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL
FROM. AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE BILL APPROVED BY UNANIMOUS
SEVEN TO ZERO VOTE. AB SEVEN
TEN POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
COST OF ATTENDANCE TO DO PASSED
WITH A MEMBERS PER AUTHORED
ALLOW FLEXIBILITY WITH HOUSING
CALCULATIONS FOR SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE KAUFER MAY BE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. THE BILL WAS
APPROVED ON. A UNANIMOUS SEVEN
TO ZERO. VOTE. MOVING TO MR
CHOW AB ONE SEVENTY THREE
MOBILE HOMES TAX FREE ABATEMENT
PROGRAM AMENDMENT WHICH HAD TO
PASS FOR THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR
TO EXTEND HDDS REPORT DEADLINE
AND PROHIBIT. PARTICIPATION OF
AN APPLICANT TOOK OWNERSHIP OF
THE MOBILE HOME THROUGH A
WAREHOUSE LEAN THAT IS
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
A. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO. THE
BILL WAS APPROVED ON A SEVEN.
TO ZERO VOTE AB THREE NINETY
SEVEN DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE. STATISTICS TO DO
PASS FOR THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR
TO ACQUIRE THE COURTS INSTEAD
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT TO SUBMIT
SPECIFIED INFORMATION.
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE CAR FROM
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL'S
APPROVED THE UNANIMOUS SEVEN.
TO ZERO VOTE. AB TWELVE OH TWO
DATA BROKERS IT'S AMENDMENTS TO
DO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS TO
SPECIFY THAT A DATA BROKER MAY
SATISFY SPECIFIC OBLIGATIONS TO
CONSUMERS. BY PROVIDING A
NOTICE ON ITS HOMEPAGE OR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE THREE TO THAT BILLS
APPROVED ON A FIVE TO. VOTE
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING. NO AB
TWELVE EIGHTY ONE FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY THAT TO
DO PASS OR SUBSTANCE THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE THREE OR TWO.
THE BILL WAS APPROVED. ON A
FIVE TO VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. MR CHAN AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN CITY OF BREA RDA
PROPERTY TAX OVERRIDE RATES AT
TO DO PAST SUMMER SUBSTITUTING
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL WAS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS SEVEN
TO ZERO. VOTE. WERE MOVING TO
MISTER TO A. B. FOUR FIVE SIX
ON PUBLIC CONTRACTS. THERE'S NO
INTERESTING BILLS HERE STERN
TRIES TO TAKE A BREAK AT THIS
POINT. I WILL KEEP GOING AB FOR
FIFTY SIX WITH THIS TO DO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
INSERT A SUNSET DATE SUBSTANCE
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL
WAS APPROVED ON THE UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF SEVEN. TO ZERO AB.
EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN PUBLIC BANKS
THEIR MEMBERS PER AUTHOR. TO
LIMIT THE NUMBER BANKS REQUIRE
REPORT AND MAKE OTHER
CLARIFYING CHANGES AND THEN
THERE ARE. MANY MEMBERS TO
AMEND THE SUNSET A MAN TO
SUNSET THE PILOT AFTER SEVEN
YEARS SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE THREE OR TWO THAT
BILLS APPROVED ON A FIVE TO
VOTE. WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW AB NINE FORTY THREE WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES A STUDENT
EQUITY IN THE TREATMENT PROGRAM
FUND THAT'S TO DO PASS WE'RE
GONNA DO A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO I WANT YOU KNOW I
BATES. BRADFORD BRADFORD I
DORADO. DORADO AYE HILL HILL
AYE JONES JONES I Y. KOWSKI
MAKOWSKI AYE. THAT IS A SIX TWO
ZERO MOVING ON AB THIRTEEN
FORTY ON PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION TO DO PASSED WITH A
MEMBER WITH THE MEMONS PER
AUTHOR TO MAKE THE BILL
OPERATIVE AFTER THE I. T.
SYSTEM IS READY AND MAKE OTHER
CHANGES. OR SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THAT BILL WAS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS SEVEN
TO ZERO. AND VOTE. AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO IS A TO PASS TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE. AND WE ARE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB THREE OH TWO THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A FIVE TO VOTE WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING. NO ACR
FIFTY WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT IS
A TO PASS. AND THAT IS A SUB TO
ROLL CALL FOR MAY BE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL WAS
APPROVED. SEVEN TWO ZERO. MR
CHOI AB SIX SEVEN SEVEN
INTERCOUNTRY ADOPTION FINALIZED
IN A FOREIGN COUNTRY THAT BILL
IS A DO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS
PER AUTHORED OR- REQUIRE THE
ADOPTION AGENCY TO REPORT AN
ADOPTEE'S ARRIVAL DATE TO DSS.
THAT'S A SUBSET TO ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO.
THE BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS SEVEN TO ZERO THE
VOTE. MR TWO AB TWO EIGHT THREE
CAL WORKS IMMUNIZATION AND
TRUANCY THAT IS A TO PASS WITH
THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO
SPECIFY THAT MEDICARE WILL
PROVIDE COVERAGE FOR NON
MEDICAL TRANSPORTATION AND TO
LAY IMPLEMENTATION. A MANTO
REMOVE THE FIFTY DOLLAR
SANCTION SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM THREE OH TWO THAT
BILL WAS APPROVED ON A FIVE TO
VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW. AB THREE EIGHTEEN MEDI CAL
MATERIALS READABILITY THAT IS A
TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS FOR
AUTHOR TO NARROW THE BILL'S
SCOPE OR SUBSTRING THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE THREE OH TO THE
BILL WAS APPROVED ON A FIVE TO
VOTE. WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW AB THREE THREE EIGHT MOBILE
HOME EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
THAT IS MOVED WITH A MEMBERS
PER AUTHOR TO SIMPLIFY
TRANSLATION REQUIREMENTS AND TO
SPECIFY STANDARD FOR SMOKE
ALARM INSTALLATION FOR SUBSIDY
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THREE
OH TWO. THAT BILL WAS APPROVED
ON A FIVE TO VOTE WITH
REPUBLICAN VOTING NOW AB SEVEN
TWENTY NINE CORPORATE
STEWARDSHIP THAT IS A TO PASS
AND WE ARE SUBSTANTIVE ROLE FOR
MAYBE THREE OR TO HAVE A LITTLE
PROVED. ON A FIVE TO VOTE WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. MOVING
TO MISTER COOLEY. EIGHTY TO
NINETY SIX CLIMATE INNOVATION
GRANT PROGRAM VOLUNTARY TAX
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT BILL IS A
MOVED WITH A MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR
TO ADDRESS CHAPTER ISSUES WERE
CALLING THE ROLE. PORTANTINO I
PORTANTINO AYE BATES RIGHT
BATES AYE BRADFORD. ROUTE FOR
DIED A RAZA. DORADO AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES JONES NO WAY
CASKEY MAKOWSKI AYE. THE BILL
IS OUT SIX TO ONE MOVING TO A.
B. TEN SIXTY EIGHT CHILD AND
FAMILY TEAMS. TO DO PASS FOR
THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED A
STRIKE THE NEUTRAL FACILITATOR
INVITE THE EDUCATION RIGHTS
HOLDER. TO SEE A TEAM MEETINGS
AND AUTHORIZES SUMMARY TO BE
ATTACHED TO THE COURT REPORT.
SUBS TO THE ROLE FOR AB THREE
EIGHTY TWO BILLS APPROVED ON A
SEVEN TO ZERO. VOTE AB FIFTEEN
NINETY ONE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER LEGISLATIVE
REPORTING THAT IS DO PASSED
WITH AMENDMENTS TO STRIKE. THE
PROVISION TO SUPPORT
LEGISLATORS ATTENDANCE AT
MEETINGS SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO BILLS APPROVED ON A SEVEN
TO ZERO VOTE MISTER COOPER AB
TWO SEVEN ONE CIVIL SERVICE
SALARY EQUALIZATION IS A TO
PASS. SOME SHOULD ROLL CALL
FROM THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL'S APPROVED ANY NATOMAS
SEVEN TO ZERO VOTE AB THREE
FORTY SIX WORKERS SIX WORKERS
COMPENSATION LEAVES OF ABSENCES
THAT IS GOING TO BE A ROLL CALL
VOTE. PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO
AYE BATES. VOTING BRADFORD ARE
BRADFORD AYE TO RAZA. TORONTO I
HELD HILL AYE JONES JONES I Y.
CASKEY MAKOWSKI AYE. THE BILL
IS OUT SIX ZERO AB TEN THIRTY
THREE STATE EMPLOYMENT NEW
EMPLOYEE INFORMATION THE TO
PASS SUBSTANTIVE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL IS APPROVED ANY UNANIMOUS
SEVEN TO ZERO. VOTE MISTER
CUNNINGHAM AB SIX SIX TWO
CRIMES AGAINST MINORS. TO PASS
A SUBSIDY TO ROLL CALL FROM A.
B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL'S APPROVED ANY INANIMATE
SEVEN TO ZERO. VOTE MR DAILY.
AB THREE FIVE FIVE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE RELATIONS BOARD ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
PERCEPTIONS IN THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE THREE OR TO THE
BILL'S APPROVED FIVE TO TWO WAS
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. TO DO
PASSED MOTIONS HIS ME AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR CEILING OF
RECORDS IS ALSO TO PASS AND
THAT IS A SUBSIDY ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL IS APPROVED ANY UNANIMOUS
SEVEN TWO ZERO VOTE. AB
THIRTEEN SHOULD BE SEVENTEEN
THIRTY SIX NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR CONTRACT AND
SUBCONTRACTORS IS A TO PASS.
THAT AS A SUBSTITUTE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE. THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE BILL IS APPROVED BY
UNANIMOUS VOTE SEVEN. ZERO
EGGMAN A. B. THREE THREE THREE
WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTION IS A
TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS FOR
AUTHOR TO MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES RECEPTIVE TO THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE THREE OH TO THE
BILL IS APPROVED FIVE TO TWO
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW SB
SIX FOURTEEN INCOME TAX CREDIT
FOOD BANKS IS A TO PASS SUB TO
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL IS APPROVED
ON UNANIMOUS VOTE SEVEN TO ZERO
AB SEVEN EIGHTEEN DEPENDENT
CHILDREN DOCUMENTS THAT IS A DO
PAST SUMMER STEPS TO THE ROLL
CALL. MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS SEVEN TO ZERO VOTE AB
FIFTEEN EIGHTY THREE CALIFORNIA
RECYCLING MARKET DEVELOPMENT
ACT THAT IS A DO PASS THE SUBS
TO THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO BILLS
APPROVED BY UNANIMOUS SEVEN TO
ZERO VOTE. WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
QUICK LITTLE BREAK AND I'LL BE
RIGHT
. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
GO BACK. TO CALL THIS MEETING
BACK TO ORDER. IN A MOVE TO
MISTER FLORA. AB FIVE FIFTY
VETERANS MEMORIAL PICTURES
MEMES VETERANS MEDICAL FOSTER
HOME PILOT PROGRAM. TO DO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR. TO
SPECIFY THE FREQUENCY FOR
CHECKING THE HOME. CARE AIDE
REGISTRY THAT IS A TO PASS WITH
THOSE AMENDMENTS. THERE IS SET
TO THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO. THE BILL
WAS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
SEVEN ZERO VOTE AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY TWO CITY OF MANTECA
ALREADY A SUCCESSOR AGENCY
PROPERTY. THAT IS A TO PASS
WITH THE SUB TO ROLL CALL FOR
MAY BE SET AT THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO. IS APPROVED BY UNANIMOUS
SEVEN TO ZERO BOTH. MOVING TO
MISTER FRAZIER AB SEVEN OH TWO
TRAFFIC VIOLATORS SCHOOL
RESTRICTIONS THAT IS A DO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
TRACK DATA SECURITY AND SCHOOL
LISTENING PROVISIONS. DELAY THE
OPERATIVE DATE AND MAKE. BUT I
SAY. TO HELP SORRY SEVEN OH
EIGHT. YOU CAN LAUGH. OKAY.
SEVEN OH EIGHT EIGHT DOESN'T
LOOK ANYTHING LIKE IT TOO. AT
SEVEN OH EIGHT SO THAT IS A DO
PASSED WITH THE MEMONS PER
AUTHORED A STRIKE DATA SECURITY
IN SCHOOL LISTENING PROVISIONS
DELAY THE OPERATIVE DATE AND
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES AND
THAT IS A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO HI YOU KNOW I BATES.
BATES NO BRADFORD. BRADFORD I
TO RAZA TERRAZZO AYE HILL HILL
AYE JONES JONES I WHAT CASKEY
BY CASKEY AYE. THE BILL IS OUT
SIX TO ONE. AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
TWO ON SPECIAL EDUCATION PUBLIC
NONSECTARIAN SCHOOLS THAT IS TO
PASS WITH A MEMBERS FOR
AUTHORED REQUIRE NON PUBLIC
SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE TRAINING AND
MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL IS APPROVED ANY UNANIMOUS
SEVEN. TO ZERO VOTE AB EIGHTEEN
TEN TRANSPORTATION OMNIBUSES A
DO PASS SUBSTANTIVE ROLE KAUFER
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL'S APPROVED ON A SEVEN TO
ZERO. VOTE MS FRIEDMAN. ANOTHER
ONE THAT I KNOW OF DON'T BEYOND
NO YANNI. AS MEDIA ON A ON SO I
DON'T MAKE ME ON AB FORTY FOUR
FOR PROHIBITION THAT IS A TO
PASS WITH ONE AMENDMENT TO
CHANGE OPERATIVE DATE TO
JANUARY ONE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
THREE AND THERE'S A ROLL CALL
VOTE. PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO
AYE BATES NUMBER BRADFORD. TO
RAZA DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE
JONES. JONES NO WHITE HOUSE
GAME. MY KOWSKI EIN SPILLED
FORTY ONE THE BILL IS OUT FOR
TWO ONE. AB TWO EIGHT FIVE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION PLAN
THAT IS A DO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO REPLACE
CALTRANS AN OP ARE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS WITH STRATEGIC.
GROWTH COUNCIL WE'RE GONNA
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FROM AB
THREE OH TO THE BILL WAS
APPROVED ON A FIVE TO VOTE WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW SB SIX
SEVEN ONE ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS INCENTIVES THAT IS A TO
PASS WITH A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL. FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THE BILL IS APPROVED ANY
ANONYMOUS SEVEN TO ZERO VOTE IN
AB ELEVEN FORTY FOUR SELF
GENERATING INCENTIVE PROGRAM HI
FIRE THREAT DISTRICTS. THAT IS
A DO PASS AND WE'RE GONNA
SUBJECT THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
THREE OH TO THE BILL'S APPROVED
A FIVE TO VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS
NOTE. VOTING NO AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY RECYCLED WATER. I'M
SHARKS OR THE LAST THAT I
MESSED UP. 214-041-1404. OKAY.
SO I WOULD LIKE A MOTION TO
RECONSIDER THE VOTE ON AB
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR WE HAVE A
MOTION PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PORTANTINO BY. PORTANTINO ON A
BATES. BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE TO RAZA. DORADO
AYE HILL. HILL AYE JONES. JONES
I WIECKOWSKI. MAKOWSKI AYE. THE
MOTION TO RECONSIDER PASSES
SEVEN. TO ZERO SO WE ARE GOING
TO RE VOTE ON AB ELEVEN FORTY
FOUR WHICH IS A TO PASS. A
MEMBER AND WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FOR MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO. THE BILL
IS APPROVED SEVEN. TO ZERO AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY RECYCLED WATER.
THAT IS A DO PASS AND WE ARE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE
FROM A. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO.
THAT BILL IS APPROVE SEVEN. TO
ZERO. AB FIFTEEN SIXTEEN FIRE
PREVENTIVE PREVENTION
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND FUELS
REDUCTION. THAT IS A DO PASS
WITH AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW S. D.
G. AN E. TO ENFORCE THE GUIDE
BOOK RECOMMENDATIONS ONLY IN
HIGH FIRES OWN THREAT. AREAS
AND THAT IS A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. ABILITY BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE DERISIVE. TORONTO
AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES. CASKEY
MAKOWSKI AYE. THE BILL IS OUT
FIVE TO ZERO MOVING TO MR
GABRIEL AB ONE SIXTY SIX THAT
IS A DO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS
FOR AUTHOR TO SPECIFY REPORT
COMPONENTS AND AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES
THE SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM A. B. THREE OH TWO BILLS
APPROVED ON A FIVE TO VOTE WITH
REPUBLICANS. VOTING NOW AB
SEVEN FIFTY TWO LIKE TATIAN
ROOMS AS A TO PASS AND WE'RE
SECTION ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THOSE
APPROVED SEVEN TO ZERO AB
ELEVEN THIRTY TWO CALLER ID
FRAUD IS A TO PASS A
SUBSTANTIVE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
THIRTY TWO THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
BILLS APPROVED BY UNANIMOUS
SEVEN. TO ZERO VOTE AB FIFTEEN
FORTY EIGHT CALIFORNIA STATE
NONPROFIT SECURITY GRANT
PROGRAM THAT IS A SUBSTITUTE TO
PASS WITH SUBSTANCE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN OUT EIGHTY
TO THE BILL'S PAST SEVEN TO
ZERO MR GALLAGHER AB FOUR FOUR
NINE FEATHER RIVER CROSSING
THAT IS A TO PASS OR
SUBSTITUTING THE MOTION THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. THE BILL PASSES
SEVEN ZERO CRIST MS GARCIA AB.
ONE FORTY TWO IS IT TO PASS. UP
TO THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
THREE OH TWO THE BILL WAS
APPROVED ON A FIVE TO VOTE.
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. AB
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN USE MATTRESS
RECOVERY AND RECYCLING ACT THAT
IS A DO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO
ALLOW THE MATTRESSES CYCLING
ORGANIZATION TO EXPAND. FUNDS
ON LITIGATION WE'RE DOING A
ROLL CALL VOTE PORTANTINO FIVE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES ALRIGHT
BATES AYE BRADFORD. BRADFORD
I'D TO RAZA. DORADO AYE HILL
HILL AYE JONES. JONES I WAKE
OWSKI BY MAKOVSKY AYE. THE LOS
OUT SEVEN ZERO. AB THREE SIXTY
FIVE ON STATE CIVIL SERVICE
EXAMINATION AND HIRING PROCESS
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO DELETE
THE TASK FORCE TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF AFFECTED STATE
DEPARTMENT'S RECEPTION IN THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILLS APPROVED
BY UNANIMOUS SEVEN TO ZERO VOTE
SB SIX FORTY NINE GIMLI CONTROL
ACT EMPLOYMENT AGE. LIKE A ROLL
CALL VOTE ON THIS. THAT IS A DO
PASS. OKAY. SOMETIMES MY DAD
JUST TAKES OVER. THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE DAD BILLS ANYWAY WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO A SUBSTITUTE
ROLE KAUFER MAY BE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL IS APPROVED
ANY ANONYMOUS SEVEN. TO ZERO
VOTE. AB THREE EIGHTY SIX.
HIGHER CULTURE WORKERS ENERGY
EFFICIENT OUR ON MISTER GARCIA.
AB THREE EIGHTY SIX IS A DO
PASS AND WE'RE GONNA DO A ROLL
CALL VOTE. PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD I DORADO.
TORONTO AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES
JONES NO WHITE HOUSE KING BY
CASKEY AYE. THE BILL IS OUT SIX
TO ONE AB TEN TEN TRAVEL
ELIGIBLE ELIGIBILITY STATE
HOUSING PROGRAMS AS A DO PASS
AND WE'RE GONNA SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLE FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO APPLE IS APPROVED ANY
INANIMATE SEVEN. TO ZERO VOTE
AB TWELVE FORTY EIGHT CAPITAL
INVESTMENT INCENTIVE PROGRAM.
WE ARE TO DO PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO EXPAND THE
PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY FOR
SPECIFIED PRODUCTION FACILITIES
THAT IS A SUBSIDY ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL IS APPROVED ON UNANIMOUS
SEVEN TO ZERO. VOTE. MR GIPSON.
AB ONE SEVEN FIVE FOSTER CARE
BILL OF RIGHTS WERE MENDING FOR
AUTHOR TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES AND TO ADD CO AUTHORS
RECEPTION ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
THREE OH TWO THE BILL WAS
APPROVED ON A FIVE TO VOTE WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW AB SEVEN
FORTY EIGHT NINE MINOR
DEPENDENCE SO THAT IS A DO
PASS. RECEPTION ROLL CALL. TO
DO PASS. WE'RE SUBJECT TO THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL WAS
APPROVED AT A UNANIMOUS SEVEN
TO ZERO. AB EIGHT OH THREE PEER
SUPPORT LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE. THAT IS A TO PASS
AND WE ARE SUBSIDIZING THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO. THE BILL IS APPROVED THEN
UNANIMOUS SEVEN TO ZERO. VOTE
AB EIGHT SIX EIGHT SEVEN NINE
FIREARMS THAT IS A D. PASS AND
WE'RE DOING A ROLL CALL.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
DRAWS IN TORONTO AYE HILL HILL
AYE JONES. JONES NO WAY CASCADE
HIGH MAKOWSKI AYE FIVE TWO ONE.
THE BILL WAS OUT FIVE TO ONE.
EIGHTY NINE A ONE ON JUVENILES
IT'S A TO PASS. OR SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM AB THREE OH TO
THE BILL WAS APPROVED ON A FIVE
TO VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW. AB THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE
COASTAL PORTS AUTOMATED
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS A D. PASS
AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FOR MAYBE THREE OF TWO. BILLS
APPROVED WITH A FIVE TO VOTE.
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY FOR JUVENILE
COURT SCHOOLS TRANSITION
PLANNING POLICIES THAT IS A TO
PASS RECEPTION THE ROLE FOR
MAYBE THREE TO. THAT BILLS
APPROVED ON A FIVE TO VOTE WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. A
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR COMMUNITY
PARAM PARA MEDICINE OR TRY ASH
TO ALTERNATE DESTINATION ACT
THAT IS A DO PASS WITH THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO CLARIFY.
RIGH OF FIRST REFUSAL
PROVISIONS AND MAKE OTHER
CHANGES. THAT IS A SUBSTANTIVE
ROLL CALL FROM THREE OH TWO.
THAT BILLS APPROVED A FIVE TO
VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW. ABOUT ONE SECOND. ALL
RIGHT SO AB FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR
COMMUNITY FERRAMENTA WE DID
THAT ONE RIGHT YES EXPAND ON
THAT WAS OUT OKAY. MR GLORIA AB
FOURTEEN SHE MAY BE FOR TWENTY
THREE SAN DIEGO COUNTY AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT.
AMENDS FOR AUTHOR TO REQUIRE
THE DISTRICT TO REPORT ON
SPECIFIED APPLICATION. MEN'S
FOR AUTHOR TO REQUIRE THE
DISTRICT REPORT ON SPECIFIED
APPLICATION ACTIVITIES AND MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES SUBS TO THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THREE OH
TWO THAT BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
FIVE TO VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS.
VOTING NOW. WE'RE GOING TO.
RIGHT. FOR MANY THIRTY OKAY FOR
A YEAR HE SWITCHING FASTER THAN
I'M READING AB FOR NINETY THREE
TEACHER TRAINING LGBT Q.
STUDENTS. THAT IS A TO PASS AND
WE'RE DOING A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BRADFORD BRADFORD I TO
RAZA RAZA AYE HILL HILL AYE
JONES JONS NO WAY CASKEY
MAKOWSKI AYE FIVE TO ONE THAT
IS OUT FIVE TO ONE. AB EIGHT
NINETY THREE FIREARM AND
AMMUNITION SALES AT THE DEL MAR
FAIRGROUNDS THAT IS AMENDMENTS
PER AUTHOR TO MAKE FINDINGS AND
DECORATIONS RELATED TO GUN
SHOWS A PUBLIC SAFETY RISKS.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THREE OH
TWO THAT BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
FIVE TO VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NOW. AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR PUBLIC RECORDS THAT IS A
MEMBER AS A TO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO MAKE
DEFINITIONAL AND CONFORMING
CHANGES PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES BATES AYE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I TO RAZA.
DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES
JONS NO WAY CASKEY MAKOWSKI AYE.
SIXTEEN HOLD ON ONE SECOND FIVE.
ALL RIGHT SO. SIX THE ONE THE
BILL IS OUT SIX TO ONE. SYSTEM
WORK. SIXTY ONE AB TWELVE
THIRTY TWO WHETHER A STATION
THAT IS A DO PASS FOR AUTHOR TO
EXPAND SEIZE S. DIS RELATED TO
MAKE RULES FOR ENERGY SAVINGS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE KAUFER MAY
BE. THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THAT
BILL IS APPROVED SEVEN TO ZERO
.
MS GONZALEZ AB FIVE WORKERS
STATUS EMPLOYEE AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS THAT BILL IS OUT
WITH THE MEMONS TO READ FIND
THE OPERATION OF THE A. B. C.
TEST MODIFIED INDUSTRIAL
CATEGORIES. UNDER THE BROILER
TEST AND MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES EXCEPT THROUGH THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE THREE OH TWO
THAT THAT WAS APPROVED ON A
FIVE TO. VOTE AB FIFTY ONE
EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION
ENFORCEMENT THAT IS A TO PASS
OR SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE THREE OH TWO THAT
BILL WAS APPROVED ON A FIVE TO
VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING.
NO AB ONE SEVEN ONE. RIGHT YES
YEAH ONE SEVEN ONE EMPLOYMENT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT THAT BILL IS
A DO PASS AND WE ARE SUB TO THE
ROLE FOR MAYBE THREE OH TO THE
BILL'S APPROVED WITH A FIVE. TO
VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
AB TWO EIGHTEEN CHILDHOOD
SEXUAL ASSAULT THAT IS TO DO
PASSED WITH A MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO ALLOW VICTIM TO
RECOVER. UP TO A TRIP UP TO
TREBLE DAMAGES FOR A PROVEN
COVER UP IF IT IS NOT
PROHIBITED BY ANOTHER LAW AND
TO. SPECIFY THE CHANGES TO
COMMENCE CERTAIN ACTIONS ARE
NOT TO BE CONSTRUED AS
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES IN
NEGLIGENCE LAW. AND SO WE'RE
GONNA DO A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO I WANT TO KNOW AYE
BATES. BRADFORD BRADFORD I
DORADO. DRAWS AWAY HILL. HILL
AYE JONES. JONES NUMBER CASKEY
MAKOWSKI AYE. THE BILL IS OUT
FIVE TO ONE AB FIVE HUNDRED
SCHOOL COMMITTEE COLLEGE
EMPLOYEE PAID MATERNITY LEAVE
THAT IS A ROLL CALL VOTE THE TO
DO PASS PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I TO RAZA DORADO AYE
HILL. HILL AYE JONES JONS NO
WAY CASKEY MAKOWSKI AYE. THE
BILL IS OUT FIVE TO ONE. FOR
MOVE AB SIX SIX EIGHT
PRIVILEGES FROM CIVIL RASH THAT
IS A TO PASS. RECEPTION THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THREE OUT
TO THAT BILLS APPROVED ON A
FIVE TO VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING. NO SB SIX EIGHTY ONE
VOTER REGISTRATION FOR
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY ELECTIONS
THAT IS TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS
PER AUTHOR TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF REQUIRED MAILINGS AND MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES RECEPTION IN
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THREE OH
TWO. THE BILL IS APPROVED FIVE.
TO AB. SEVEN SEVEN THREE VOTER
EDUCATION HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
THAT IS A DO PASSED WITH A ROLL
CALL VOTE. PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I DORADO TERRAZZO AYE
HELL HILL AYE JONES JONES NO
WAY CASKEY. MAKOWSKI I. FIVE TO
ONE THE BILL WAS OUT FIVE TO
ONE A. B. TEN SIXTY SIX THE
BATTLE OF HASTINGS UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE ELIGIBILITY FOR
BENEFITS DURING TRADE DISPUTES
THAT IS A TO PASS WITH THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO REDUCE
THE WAITING PERIOD FROM FOUR
WEEKS TO THREE WEEKS. OUR SUBS
TO THE ROLE FOR MAYBE THREE OH
TWO APPLES APPROVED ON A FIVE
TO VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NO. AB TEN EIGHTY CALIFORNIA
SURFER ECONOMY IN PLASTIC
PRODUCER REDUCTION ACT THAT IS
A TO PASS AND WE'RE GONNA CALL
THE ROLL. PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I TO RAZA DORADO AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES. JONS NO
WAY CASKEY HI MY CASKEY AYE.
OPPOSE OUT FIVE TO ONE. AB
TWELVE NINETY SIX TAX RECOVERY
IN THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY
CRIMINAL ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM AS
A DO PASS SUB TO THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
APPLES APPROVED OUT OF SEVEN TO
ZERO VOTE. AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
SIX. FOR AN I. P. ENABLED COST
COMMUNICATION SERVICES AT TO DO
PASS RECEPTION THE ROLE KAUFER
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
APPLES APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
SEVEN TO ZERO VOTE AB. SIXTEEN
EIGHTY ONE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES.
COLLECTIVE A PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING UNIT
DETERMINATIONS THAT IS A TO
PASS. THANKS TO THE ROLE FROM
THE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL APPROVED BY UNANIMOUS VOTE
SEVEN. ZERO AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
SEVEN LAW ENFORCEMENT MEMBERS
PER AUTHORED A NARROW THE SCOPE
OF THE BILL TO THE TO CLASS
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE THREE TO THAT AS A BILL
THE BILL WAS APPROVED ON A FIVE
TO VOTE. WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. A CA FOURTEEN UC
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY EMPLOYMENT
STANDARDS THAT IS A DO PASSED
WITH AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO
MAKE FIRE FIND CHANGES
RECEPTION THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE THREE OH TWO. THAT BILL
WAS APPROVED ON A FIVE TO VOTE
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING. NOW.
WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU MISTER
GRAY AB SIX THIRTY EIGHT WATER
STORAGE CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS
THAT IS A DO PASSED WITH THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO MAKE DATA
DEPOSITS PERMISSIVE. SAYS
MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO MAKE DATA
DEPOSITS PERMISSIVE. SUB TO
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THAT BILLS APPROVED
BY UNANIMOUS SEVEN ZERO VOTE AB
EIGHT FORTY EIGHT MEDI CAL
CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE MONITORS
THAT IS A TO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO CLARIFY
THE DEPARTMENT CAN IMPLEMENT
BILL THROUGH SPECIFIED NON
REGULATORY MEANS PERCEPTION
ROLL CALL FOR A. B. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THAT BILLS APPROVED
AN INANIMATE SEVEN. TO ZERO.
VOTE THREE TAKE ANOTHER.
ANOTHER QUICK BREAK I'LL BE
RIGHT BACK
. I'M GONNA TAKE A
TEN MINUTE RECESS EVERYBODY
RELAX. WE'LL BE BACK IN TEN
MINUTES
. WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK
TO WORK GOING TO MISTER GRAYSON
AB ONE EIGHTY FIVE. JOINT
MEETINGS OF THE CTC CARP AND H.
C. D. THAT IS A TO PASS. WE ARE
FILE WHICH CAN CALL ROLE SO
WE'RE GONNA Là. LISTEN TO.
HELLO THERE ARE SIR ALL RIGHT
WE ARE ON MISTER GRAYSON AB ONE
EIGHTY FIVE JOINT MEETINGS OF
THE CTC CARBONATE C. D. WE ARE
GOING TO CALL THE ROLL WITH A
DO PASS PORTANTINO I YOU KNOW I
BATES BATES AYE BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE TO RAZA DORADO AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES. JONES NO
WAY CASKEY MAKOWSKI AYE. THE
BILL IS OUT SIX TO ONE AB SIX
FIFTY ONE AIR AMBULANCE
SERVICES. THERE'S A MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO SPECIFY A TO DO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO
SPECIFY THE SUPPLEMENTAL MEDI
CAL PAYMENT AMOUNTS MAKE
IMPLEMENTATION CONTINGENT UPON
A BUDGET APPROPRIATION. AND TED
CO AUTHORS WE'RE GONNA
SUBSTANCE TO ROLL CALL. FROM AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THOSE
APPROVED SEVEN. TWO ZERO FIVE
AB TEN TWENTY FIVE SAN RAMON
BRANCH COURT OR REIMBURSEMENT
OF STATE FUNDS A TO DO PASSED.
IN A SUB TO THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE THREE OH TO THE BILL'S
APPROVED FIVE TO. WITH
REPUBLICANS RUNNING NOW AB ONE
ONE ONE SIX FIREFIGHTERS PEER
SUPPORT AS A DO PASSED WITH THE
MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED REMOVED
CAL YES PROVISIONS AND REMOVE
THE SUNSET DATE. SUB TO THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL IS APPROVED
ANY NATOMAS SEVEN TO ZERO. VOTE
AB ONE ONE ONE SEVEN PEACE
OFFICERS THAT IS UP TO THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO BILLS APPROVED. ON THE
UNANIMOUS SEVEN TO ZERO VOTE.
THE TO PASS MOTION APPROVED
SEVEN ZERO A. B. FOURTEEN A.
THREE HOUSING DATA AMENDMENTS
TO STRIKE PARCEL DATABASE
PROVISIONS APR REQUIREMENTS.
CAN A REPORTING EIGHT CD DATA
PUBLICATIONS AS A SUB TO ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THE BILL'S APPROVE SEVEN.
TO ZERO. FOR THE MISTER HOLDEN
AB TWENTY NINE STATE HIGHWAY
ROUTE SEVEN TEN THERE'S A
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO DELAY
REMOVAL OF PORTIONS IS THAT S.
R. SEVEN TEN FROM THE FREEWAY
SYSTEM. MAKE OTHER SPECIFIED
ALTERNATIVES IN FEASIBLE AND A
ONE TECHNICAL AMENDMENT A. B.
THAT'S. WE'RE GOING TO ROLL
CALL ON AB TWENTY NINE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. NO BATES NO BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE TO RAZA DORADO AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES JONS NO WAY
CASKEY MAKOWSKI AYE. THE BILL
IS OUT FIVE TO WITH A. B.
THIRTY COLLEGE AND CAREERS
ACCESS PATHWAYS TO MEMBERS FOR
AUTHORED A STREAMLINED APPROVAL
PROCESSES TO DO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS. SORRY IT REALLY
MEANT I DID. FOR AUTHORED A
STREAMLINED APPROVAL PROCESS.
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL I DID
IT BACKWARDS THAT SUBSIDY ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO APPLES APPROVE SEVEN. TO
ZERO AB NINE FOURTEEN MEDI CAL
INMATE'S ELIGIBILITY THAT IS DO
PASS FOR THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHORED TO DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT
SEVERABILITY PROVISIONS SUBSIDY
TO ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILLS APPROVED
BY UNANIMOUS SEVEN TO ZERO.
VOTE AB TEN SEVENTY FIVE CSU.
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGIST.
THAT IS A TO PASS SUB TO THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO BILLS APPROVE SEVEN
TO ZERO. AB TEN NINETY SEVEN
PEOPLE CREDIT RECOVERY PROGRAMS
THAT IS A DO PASS UP TO THE
ROLL CALL FROM A. B. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILLS FOR SEVEN.
ZERO A. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT STUDY OF OIL AND GAS
WELLS THAT IS A ROLL CALL VOTE
AND TO PASS MOTION. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL PORTANTINO I CONTINUE
AYE BATES. BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I TO RAZA THROW SO I
HILL HILL AYE JONES. JONES NO
WHITE HOUSE KING MY CASKEY AYE.
THE BILL WAS OUT SIX THE ONE
MOVING THE MEASURE WHEN AB
TWELVE GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDERS IS TO DO PASS. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PORTANTINO. YOU
KNOW WHY PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
THE V. TWELVE CORRECT CORRECT.
BRADFORD BRADFORD I TO RAZA
DORADO AYE HILL. HELLO I JONES
JONES NO WAY CASKEY MAKOWSKI
AYE. THAT IS OUT FIVE TO ONE AB
THREE THREE NINE IS A TO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO
MAKE G. V. R. O. TRAINING
PERMISSIVE AS A SUBSIDY ROLL
CALL A. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THAT THAT WAS OUT SEVEN TO
ZERO. WITH AB THREE FORTY ARMED
PROHIBITED PERSONS THERE'S A
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED TO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS PROFIT TO
NARROW THE SCOPE OF TO A
REPORTING REQUIREMENT RECEPTION
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO BILLS APPROVED ANY
NATOMAS VOTE. OF SEVEN TO ZERO.
AB EIGHT EIGHT FIVE PROPERTY
TAXATION NEW CONSTRUCTION
DEFINITION THAT IS A D. PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS PER AUTHORED
AND CO AUTHORS SUB TO THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO. IT WAS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF SEVEN. TO ZERO AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
PROGRAM THAT IS TO DO PASS
MOTION AND IT IS SUBJECT TO THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. BILLS APPROVED
SEVEN TO ZERO. COMING TO
DISTRICT JONES SAWYER AB THIRTY
SEVEN PERSONAL INCOME TAX
DEDUCTIONS COMMERCIAL CANNABIS
BUSINESS EXPENSES. THAT IS A TO
PASS FOR THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR
CODIFY THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENT MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PORTANTINO ON A PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BATES NO BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE TO RAZA. RAZA Y.
HILL. HILL AYE JONES. JONES I
WAKE OWSKI MY CASKEY AYE. THE
BILL IS OUT SIX TWO ONE AB TWO
FIFTY EIGHT SCHOOL BASED PEOPLE
SUPPORT SERVICES THAT BILL IS
OUT. OVER IS TO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED AND
REQUIREMENTS TO GRANT
APPLICATION PROCESS SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO. BILLS
APPROVE SEVEN TO ZERO MAYBE
THREE OR FOUR WIRE TAPPING IT
TO DO PASS. SUB TO THE ROLL
CALL FROM THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE BILL'S APPROVE. SEVEN TO
ZERO EIGHTY NINE TWENTY SEVEN
DEFENDANTS ABILITY TO PAY. AS A
DO PASSED WITH A MEMBERS FOR
AUTHORED EXPAND THE ABILITY TO
PAY DETERMINATION REQUIREMENT
TO MINORS WE'RE GOING TO ROLL
CALL VOTE. PORTANTINO I WANT TO
KNOW AYE BATES BATES AYE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE TO RAZA.
DORADO AYE HILL. HILL AYE JONES
JONES NO AYE CASKEY CASKEY I.
THE BILL IS OUT SIX TWO ONE
THAT WAS NINE TWENTY SEVEN
RIGHT. MOVING TO ONE THOUSAND
SEVEN STATE CIVIL SERVICE ACT
NOTICE OF ADVERSE ACTIONS IT IS
A DO PASS SUB TO THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE THREE OR TO THE
BILL'S OUT FIVE TO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW AB TEN
NINETY TWO CHILD SUPPORT THAT
IS A DO PASSED WITH A MEMBERS
FOR AUTHOR PROHIBIT THE
COLLECTION OF INTEREST. THAT
ACCRUES STARTING IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO. SUB TO THE
BOAT FROM AB THREE OH TWO THAT
IS A FIVE TO VOTE WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. AB
TWELVE NINETEEN TEACHER SIMON
MONITORING THAT IS TO PASS FOR
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHORED. TO
DESIGNATE THE CHARTER
AUTHORIZED AUTHORIZED AS A
MONITORING ENTITY. THAT SUBSIDY
TO ROLL FROM THREE OO TO THE
BILL IS OUT FIVE TO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. AB
TWELVE NINETY ONE CANNABIS
LICENSING APPLICATION THAT IS A
DO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHORED AND LICENSING AND WE
ENTITIES INTO THE BILL'S
PURVIEW. SUBSTANCE ROLE FROM AB
THREE OH TO THE BILL'S OUT
FIVE. TO TWO WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NOW AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
FOUR CALIFORNIA OLYMPIC AND
PARALYMPIC PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMAND SAID TO PASS SUB TO THE
ROLL CALL FROM THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THE BILLS OUT. SEVEN ZERO.
MISTER KALRA AB THIRTY FIVE
WORKER SAFETY BLOOD LEAD LEVELS
THAT IS A DO PASS SUBJECT TO
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THREE OR TO
THE BILL'S OUT FIVE TO TWO.
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW AB
FIFTY NINE ELECTIONS POLLING
PLACES COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES WE'RE GONNA DO A ROLL
CALL VOTE TO DO PASS.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BRADFORD. BUT FIRST I'D
RAZA DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE
JONES JONES NO WAY CASKEY HI MY
COUNTY I. THE BILL IS OUT FIVE
TO ONE. AB FOR A THREE DIVISION
OF LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT
COMPLAINTS TO PASS IS THE
MOTION SUB TO THE ROLE FOR
MAYBE THREE OR TO THE BILL'S
OUT FIVE TO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW SB SIX
TWENTY FIVE PUBLIC TRANSIT
SERVICE CONTRACTS RETENTION OF
EMPLOYEES THAT IS A DO PASS OR
SOMETHING THE ROLE FOR MAYBE
THREE OH TO THE BILL'S OUT FIVE
TO TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NO. AB SEVEN THIRTY ONE
HEALTHCARE RATE REVIEW THE TO
DO PASSED WITH THE MEMBERS FOR
AUTHOR THE IMPLEMENTATION
EXTEND TIME PERIOD TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES THE SUBZERO
CALL FROM THREE OO TO THE BILLS
OUT FIVE TO AB SEVEN YES. WITH
REPUBLICANS RUNNING NOW AB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX STERN
IDENTIFIERS CHILDCARE
DEVELOPMENT IT'S TO PASS FOR
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHORED REMOVE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
REQUIREMENTS AND LINK DATA WHEN
STUDENTS ARE ENROLLED IN EARLY
CHILDHOOD PROGRAMS SUB TO THE
ROLE FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THE BILLS OUT SEVEN TO ZERO
AB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO LODGING
ESTABLISHMENTS SMALL PLASTIC
BOTTLES. MEN PER AUTHORED TO
DELETE THE NOTICE REQUIREMENT
AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM AB THREE OH TO THE BILL'S
OUT FIVE TO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT THAT IS A TO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR
ALIGN THE BILL WITH CURRENT
REGULATIONS WERE SUB TO THE
ROLL CALL FROM THREE OR TWO. TO
THE BILL IS OUT FIVE TO TWO
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW IS
CALM LONGER DOVE AB. ONE EIGHTY
NINE MANDATED REPORTERS AS A DO
PASS. SUB TO THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL IS OUT SEVEN. TO ZERO. AB
TWELVE FIFTY FOUR BOB CATS.
THERE ARE MOMENTS TO MAKE
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO THE RE
OPENING OF THE BOBCAT SEIZING
CONTINGENT UPON. AN
APPROPRIATION IN THE BUDGET
.
I'M BACK TO TWELVE FIFTY FOUR
WE'RE GONNA GO RIGHT TO IT
WITHIN TAKE ABOUT TWO MINUTES
TO RESCIND WE'RE GONNA GO TO AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED. EMPLOYMENT
SAFETY FIRE FIGHTING EQUIPMENT
THAT IS A TO PASS. UP WE'RE
GONNA DO A ROLL CALL VOTE ON A.
B. FOURTEEN HUNDRED. PORTANTINO
AYE PORTANTINO AYE BATES BATES
NO BRADFORD. BRADFORD I TO RAZA
TORONTO AYE HILL. HILL AYE
JONES JONES NO WAY CASKEY HI MY
CASKEY I. THAT IS FIVE TWO TWO
WE ARE GOING TO COME BACK AND
AB TWELVE FIFTY FOUR I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE WE'RE DOING
WHAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING. AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
MISTER KILEY A. B. FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX STATE ROUTE ONE
NINETY THREE RELINQUISHMENT
IT'S A TO PASS. SUB TO THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THAT BILLS APPROVED ANY
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF SEVEN TO ZERO.
MORE MOVING TO MISTER LACKEY AB
ONE SIXTY NINE GUIDE SIGNAL OR
SERVICE DOGS. THAT IS A DO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
PEACE OFFICERS MUST STAY UNTIL
AN ANIMAL CONTROL A LOT ARRIVES
FOR SURFING THE ROLL CALL HE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO. THAT IS A
TO PASS SEVEN TO ZERO AB FOR
TWENTY CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
RESEARCH PROGRAM. THAT IS A DO.
TO PASS WHAT'S UP TO ROLL CALL
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO IT'S A
SEVEN TO ZERO VOTE AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY ONE TRANSIT INDICTED
RIGHTS SERVICE ASSESSMENTS THAT
IS A DO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS
FOR AUTHOR TO EXTEND THE
DEADLINE FOR THE ASSESSMENT
RECEPTION THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO. IT
IS UNANIMOUS VOTE SEVEN TO ZERO
MR LEVINE A. B. SIX EIGHTY FOUR
BUILDING STANDARDS EVEY
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS
A DO PASS SUB TO ROLL CALL FOR
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL
IS APPROVED BY UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF SEVEN. TO ZERO AB ELEVEN
THIRTY PERSONAL INFORMATION THE
TO DO PASS SUB TO THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE THREE OR TWO **** ON
A FIVE TO VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS
SUPPORTING NOW ELEVEN SIXTY SIX
REGIONAL NOTIFICATION CENTER.
SYSTEM ELECTRONIC POSITIVE
RESPONSE THAT IS A TO PASS FOR
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR FILL OUT
CONTRACTORS AN EXTENSION OF
GOOD CAUSES SHOWN SUB TO ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THE BILL IS APPROVED BY
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF SEVEN. TO
ZERO AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
STATE PARKS SMOKING BAN THAT IS
A TO PASS SOME TO THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE THREE OF TO THAT
FLOWS THROUGH FIVE TO TWO.
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW THE TERM
IS NOT MY OWN AB TWO OH NINE
PARKS GRANT. PROGRAM THAT IS A
DO PASS. GOING TO ROLL CALL
VOTE. PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO
AYE BATES BRADFORD BRADFORD I
TO RAZA DORADO AYE HILL HILL
AYE JONES. JONES I WHAT CASKEY
ACCOUNTS K<c.cyan></c><c.cyan>WI. THAT IS</c>
OUT SIXTY ZERO AB FOUR OH SIX
PAID FAMILY LEAVE APPLICATIONS
IN NON ENGLISH LANGUAGES YOU
PASS. SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FOR
MAYBE THIRTEEN OF TWO BILLS
APPROVED SEVEN TWO ZERO AB FIVE
THIRTY NINE CONSUMER LOAN
CEMENT TO MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PORTANTINO I YOU KNOW I BATES.
FOR BRADFORD AYE DORADO DORADO
AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES JONES
NO WAY CASKEY MY COUNTY I. THE
BILL IS OUT FIVE TO ONE EIGHTY
FIVE FORTY CAL GRANT THE
SERVICE INCENTIVE PROGRAM A
MEMBER PER AUTHOR TO RENAME THE
PROGRAM AND MODIFY THE
VOLUNTEER SERVICE REQUIREMENTS
UP TO THE ROLE FOR MAYBE THREE
OH TWO APPLES APPROVED FIVE TO
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW
AB EIGHT FORTY TWO CHILD CARE
PRESCHOOL MEALS. THAT IS A DO
PASS WITH SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE
FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE BILL PASSES. SEVEN TWO ZERO
THREE TEN FIFTY SEVEN OIL AND
GAS WELLS FACILITY SECURITY IS
A TO PASS SUB TO THE ROLE FOR
MAYBE THREE OH TO THE BILL'S
APPROVED ON A FIVE TO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO AB
SIXTEEN EIGHTY COASTAL ACCESS
PLAN FOR HOLLISTER RANCH. MEN'S
PERON THIRTEEN SHOULD DO PASS
FOR THE MEN'S PROFIT A CHANGE
AT LINES MAKE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE FIRST PHASE CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATION WE'RE GONNA DO A
ROLL CALL VOTE PORTANTINO. AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BRADFORD
BRADFORD I TO RAZA. DORADO AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES. BY CASKEY
HI MY COUNTY I. THE BILL IS OUT
FIVE TWO ZERO. AB WERE ON TO
MISTER LOW AB ONE THIRTY HIGHER
EDUCATION PERFORMANCE
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION. THAT
IS A TO PASS AND WE'RE DOING A
ROLL CALL. PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE DERISIVE DORADO
AYE HILL. HILL AYE JONES JONES
I WAY CASKEY HI MY CASKEY AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT SIX ZERO AB
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE CURES TO PASS WERE
SUB TO THE ROLL CALL FROM
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL
WAS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO EIGHTY
FIVE FORTY FIVE ZERO CANNABIS
CONTROLLING CANNABIS CONTROL
APPEALS PANEL IS A DO PASS FOR
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
REMOVE THE APPEALS PANEL AND
EXTEND THE SUNSET. WE'RE SUB TO
THE ROLL CALL FROM THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL IS APPROVED
ANY ANONYMOUS VOTE OF SEVEN TO
ZERO AB ELEVEN THIRTY THREE
BEER PREMIUMS GIFTS AND FREE
GOODS AT THE TO PASS RECEPTION
THE ROLL CALL FROM THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL'S APPROVE
SEVEN. TO ZERO AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY ONE PETITION CIRCULATORS
TO DO PASS FOR THE MEN'S PER
AUTHOR TODAY IMPLEMENTATION TO
MAKE TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING
CHANGES RECEPTION THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE THREE OR TO THE BILL
PASSES FIVE TO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW AB
FIFTEEN NINETEEN DENTAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA. IT'S A DO PASS
RECEPTION THE ROLE KAUFER MAY
BE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL
PASSES SEVEN TO ZERO AB FIFTEEN
TWENTY COURT REPORTERS BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA THERE ARE A DO PASS
FOR THE MEN'S TO NARROW THE
SCOPE STEPS TO THE ROLE FOR
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO. WAS
APPROVED SEVEN TO ZERO AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF ACCOUNTANCY IT TO DO
PASS FOR SUB SOON ROLE FOR
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL PASSES SEVEN TO ZERO
MISTER LOW AB FIFTY TWENTY TWO
BORDER PROFESSIONAL ENGINEER
PLANTS THERE ISN'T GEOLOGISTS
TO PASS SUB TO THE ROLE FOR
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO. THE
BILL PASSES SEVEN TO ZERO MAYBE
FIFTEEN TWENTY THREE STATE
ATHLETIC CAM IN ITS TO DO PASS
AND WE'RE SUCH A FUNERAL FROM.
THIRD MAYBE TO THE BILL'S
APPROVED ME NATOMAS SEVEN TO
ZERO. WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO
.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO A.
B. TWELVE FIFTY FOUR ON BOBCATS
SO THEIR MEMBERS TO MAKE
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO THE RE
OPENING OF THE BOBCATS SEASON
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATIONS
IN THE BUDGET AND THAT IS A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON A. B. TWELVE
FIFTY FOUR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BRADFORD
BRADFORD I TO RAZA. TORONTO I
HELD HILL AYE JONES. JONS NO
WAY CASKEY HI MY CAL SKI I. SO
AB FIVE TWELVE FIFTY FOUR IS
OUT FIVE TWO ONE
. FIFTY THREE.
WE'RE GOING TO MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN AB FOR FIFTEEN
VICTIM COMPENSATION IS A TO
PASS SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FROM
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL
PASSES SEVEN TWO ZERO AB FOR
TWENTY SIX IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES TO DO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED A STRIKE
SPECIFIED PROVISIONS AND
DISALLOW MEDICAL PROVIDERS FROM
CHARGING A FORM TO ROLL CALL
VOTE PORTANTINO I YOU KNOW I
BATES. VOTING BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I DORADO DORADO AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES. JONES NO
WHITE HOUSE KING BY CASKEY AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT FIVE TO ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY FOUR
RESOURCE FAMILIES COACHING
SERVICES IT'S A TO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED AND AN
ADDITIONAL STAKEHOLDER FOR
CONSULTATION SUB TO THE ROLL
CALL FROM MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THE BILL'S APPROVE SEVEN.
TO ZERO AB EIGHT FIFTY NINE
JUDICIAL CASELOADS AMEND
DISTRICT STUDY REQUIREMENTS
CHANGE THE PURPOSE OF THE
STAKEHOLDER GROUP SUB TO THROW
CALL THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILLS OUT SEVEN TO ZERO A. B.
NINE SIXTY CAO WORKS HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE. WE IT IS DO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
CONFORM TO ELECTED BUDGET
LANGUAGE DELAY IMPLEMENTATION
TO MAKE OTHER CLARIFYING
TECHNICAL CHANGES SUB TO THE
ROLL CALL OF AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THE BILL PASSES SEVEN TO
ZERO AB TWELVE FORTY NINE
HEALTH CARE PLANS EXEMPTIONS.
TO DO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS FOR
AUTHORED REQUIRE REIMBURSEMENTS
FOR DEPARTMENT EXPENSES PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL PORTANTINO I DO
KNOW I BATES NO BATES NO
BRADFORD. BRADFORD EITHER
AWESOME DORADO AYE HILL HILL
AYE JONES. JONES NO WAY CASKEY.
MAKOWSKI AYE. THE BILL IS OUT
FIVE TO TWO. AB TWELVE SIXTY
ENDANGERED WILDLIFE FOR TO DO
PASS. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BRADFORD BRADFORD I TO
RAZA DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE
JONES JONES NOVA CASKEY I
CASKEY AYE. THE BILL WAS OUT
FIVE TO ONE. MOVING TO MISTER
MATHIS AB FIVE FIFTEEN MEDICAL
PAYMENTS INTEREST RATE SUB TO
THE ROLL CALL FROM THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL'S APPROVE
SEVEN TO ZERO. I TO DO PASS
APPROVE SEVEN TO ZERO WHICH TO
MCCARTY AB TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
PAROLEES IS TO DO PASS. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. IT'S AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE TO RAZA
TO RAZA Y. HILL HILL AYE JONES
JONES NO WAY CASKEY HI MY
CASKEY AYE. THE BILL IS OUT SIX
TO ONE. AB SIX SIX ONE WHILE
FIRE SMOKE EMERGENCY PLANS TO
PASS FOR THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS REGARDING
OTHER AIR QUALITY CONTROL
DISTRICTS SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THE BILL'S APPROVE SEVEN TO
ZERO AB ONE THOUSAND FOUR
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENING
SERVICES TO DO PASSED WITH
CEMENT WITH THE MEMBERS FOR
AUTHORED REQUIRE. HE Q. R. O.
TO REVIEW POLITY METRICS AND
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES WERE
SUB TO THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO SOUTH BILL
PASSES SEVEN TO ZERO AB TEN
EIGHTY FIVE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS SUBSTANCE USE
PREVENTION THAT IS A DO PASS
RECEPTION THE ROLL CALL FROM A.
B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL
PASSES SEVEN. TO ZERO ACR SIXTY
FOUR UC AND CSU STUDY ON THE
SAT AND ACT THAT'S A DO PASS
WE'RE GONNA DO A ROLL CALL
VOTE. PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO
AYE BATES. BRADFORD BRADFORD I
TO RAZA. DORADO AYE HILL HILL
AYE JONES JONES NO WAY CASKEY.
WATER LEVELS OUT FORTY ONE
DURING THE MISTER MEDINA AB TEN
NINETY PUBLIC POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION WAIVER OF MANDATORY
CAMPUS BASED FEES. OR SOMETHING
THAT THE TO DO PASS UP TO THE
ROLL CALL FROM THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THAT IS A SEVEN OH OUT ON A
SEVEN OH VOTE AB THIRTEEN FORTY
SIX TO RECOVERY TUITION
RECOVERY FUND THAT IS A DO PASS
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM A. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO. SO THAT
ALSO PASSES SEVEN TO ZERO MS
MELENDEZ TWELVE FOURTEEN CARDIO
PULMONARY RESUSCITATION
TRAINING. SHOULD BE PRESS I
SAID THAT WITHOUT MISSING.
SUBJECT TO THAT TO DO PASS UP
TO THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THAT FLOWS
FROM SEVEN. TO ZERO MOVING TO
MISTER MULLIN AB FIVE SEVENTY
ONE POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
CONTRIBUTION LIMITS AS A DO
PASS UP TO THE ROLE FOR MAYBE
THREE OH TWO. THE BILL IS
APPROVED FIVE TO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW AB SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR SALES AND USE
EXEMPTION HYBRID AND ZERO
EMISSIONS TRANSIT BUSES. THAT
BILL IS TO PASS AS AMENDED PER
AUTHOR EXPAND THE EXEMPTION
INCLUDE TROLLEY BUSES TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES SUBS THE ROLL
CALL. FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THE BILL'S APPROVE SEVEN TO
ZERO. MS MARSHALL IS TO
MURATSUCHI EIGHTY THIRTY NINE
L. C. F. F. FUNDING TARGETS
CEMENTED PER AUTHOR TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES SUB TO THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL WAS
APPROVED ON A SEVEN. ZERO VOTE
AB THREE OH EIGHT CORPORATION
TAX MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAXES
THAT IS A DO PASS UP TO THE
ROLL CALL FROM THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THE BILL PASSED THE SEVEN
TO ZERO. MESSAGES ARIAN AB
THREE FIVE SEVEN TAX LIABILITY
COLLECTIONS AS A TO PASS UP TO
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO. BILLS
APPROVED SEVEN TO ZERO AB FOR
TWENTY NINE SEISMIC
VULNERABILITY BUILDING
INVENTORY THANKS FOR AUTHORED
ALLOW THE COMMISSION TO DEVELOP
EITHER A MATURE YOUR SURVEY.
AND THE STRIKE THE REQUIREMENT
TO MAINTAIN THE INVENTORY SUB
TO THE ROLL CALL FROM THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL PASSES.
SEVEN TO ZERO AB SIX ELEVEN.
OUR AB SIX ELEVEN SEXUAL ABUSE
OF ANIMALS IT'S A DO PASSED
WITH THE MEMBERS PER AUTHORED
TO STRIKE. A MANDATED REPORTING
IN COUNSELING PROVISIONS. THAT
ACCEPTED THE ROLE FOR THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL'S PROOF
SEVEN. TO ZERO AB SEVEN FIFTEEN
PARKINSON'S DISEASE SUNSET
EXTENSION TO DO PASS UP TO THE
ROLE FROM THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO.
SYNONYMOUS SEVEN TO ZERO VOTE
AB TWENTY SEVENTEEN UNIVERSAL
ASSESSMENT NO WRONG DOOR
SYSTEM. THAT IS A DO PASS FOR
THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR
DESTRUCTIVE ELEMENT OF THE
PLAN. REQUIRE THE MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING CONSIDER SPECIFIED
CONCEPTS SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE
FROM THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL PASSES SEVEN. ZERO
THIRTEEN TWENTY PROHIBITS
PENSION INVESTMENTS IN TURKEY
MEN'S TO CO AUTHOR AN INSTEAD A
CO AUTHOR AND MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES. THAT IS A SUB TO ROLL
CALL FROM THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE BILL PASSES SEVEN. TO ZERO.
MR OBERNOLTE AB TWENTY EIGHT
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA STATE SEAL
OF STEM TO DO PASS ABSENT THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. TO SEPT PASSES
SEVEN TWO ZERO AB THREE NINETY
FOUR TWO QUICK EXEMPTION FOR
FIRE SAFETY GRASSROOTS SET TO
DO PASS. SUB TO THE ROLE KAUFER
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL PASSES SEVEN TO ZERO. AB
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES INFORMATION
SHARING TO DO PASS UP TO THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN.
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL PASSES
SEVEN TO ZERO MR O'DONNELL AB
FORTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO DO
PASSED THE RULES. IT'S ON K.
FOURTEEN SCHOOL FACILITIES
BONDS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PORTANTINO FIVE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BRADFORD I TO RAZA.
TERRAZZO AYE HILL HILL AYE
JONES. JONS NO WAY CASKEY HI MY
CASKEY AYE. THE BILL OF MOVES
TO RULES FIVE TO ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN FIFTY ONE PUPIL
ASSESSMENT PATHWAYS TO COLLEGE
TO DO PASS SUB TO THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THAT BILLS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF SEVEN TO ZERO
A. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY TO
ELECTRICITY RATE AND PROGRAM
INFORMATION THAT IS A DO PASS
UP TO THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO FACETS
SEVEN TO ZERO. AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY TO STATE YOUR STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT THAT TO DO
PASS UP TO THE ROLE FOR MAYBE
THREE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL'S APPROVE SEVEN TWO ZERO
A. B. FIFTEEN OH FIVE ON
CHARTER SCHOOL PETITIONS
AUTHORIZATIONS AMENDS PER
AUTHOR TO CLARIFY THE ACADEMIC
CAM ABILITY IN RENEWAL PROCESS
PROVIDE A PATH FOR TEACHERS
STERN CERTIFICATES AND TO
PROVIDE HOW FISCAL IMPACTS IS
CONSIDERED FOR NEW POSITIONS.
SUB TO THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE
THREE TO THAT BILLS APPROVED ON
A FIVE TO VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NOW AB SIXTEEN THIRTEEN
PUBLIC WORKS PREVAILING WAGES
SUCH A TO PASS SUBSTANTIVE ROLE
FOR MAYBE THREE OH TWO APPLES
APPROVED. FIVE TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. MOVING
TO MISS PETRIE-NORRIS AB FOR
SIXTY NINE STATE RECORDS
MANAGEMENT COORDINATOR TO DO
PASS SUB TO THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL'S APPROVE SEVEN. TWO ZERO
A. B. NINE NINETEEN ALCOHOLISM
AND DRUG ABUSE RECOVERY
TREATMENT PROGRAMS. THAT IS A
DO PASS AND IT IS SOMETHING THE
ROLE FROM THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE BILL PASSES SEVEN. TO ZERO
AB NINE TWENTY ALCOHOLISM IN
ABUSE RECOVERY IN TREATMENT
PROGRAMS TO DO PASS UP TO THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO IT'S A SEVEN ZERO
PASS AB NINE SIXTY THREE
STUDENTS HAVE A CONVERTER
EMPOWERMENT ACT. THAT IS A DO
PASS FOR THE MEN'S FOR AUTHORED
REDUCE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I TO RAZA TERRAZZO AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES JONES NO
WAY CASKEY MY COUNTY I. THE
BILL IS OUT FIVE TWO ONE AB
ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT PROGRAM FOR
ALL INCLUSIVE CARE FOR ELDERLY
TO PASS ACCEPTED THE ROLL CALL
FROM THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL PASSES SEVEN. TWO ZERO
MISTER QUIRK AB THREE TWENTY
SKID ONE STATEMENT IS A TO PASS
ACCEPTED THE ROLL CALL FROM
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL
PASSES SEVEN TWO ZERO AB SEVEN
THIRTY THREE. HAZARDOUS WASTE
TESTING IT TO DO PASS UP TO THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL PASSES
SEVEN TO ZERO. AB SIX SIX SEVEN
SIXTY TWO FISH AND SHELLFISH
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVISORIES IT'S A
TO PASS SUB TO THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE BILL PASSES SEVEN. ZERO A.
B. EIGHT THIRTY FOUR HARMFUL
ALGAE BLOOM PROGRAM. IT IS A D.
PASS FOR THE MEN'S FOR AUTHOR
TO REMOVE THE CENTER SETTING OF
MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR HARMFUL
ALGAE BLOOMS. RECEPTION THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL PASSES
SEVEN ZERO AB NINE FORTY FOUR
CAO WORK SPONSORED NON
CITIZENS. INDIGENOUS EXEMPTION
IT IS A DO PASSED WITH A
MEMBERS FOR AUTHORS DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION UNTIL CAL SAUCES
COMPLETE EXTEND THE TIME LINE.
FOR REGULATIONS AND AT CO
AUTHORS. SEVEN THAT BILL IS
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FROM
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO. AND IT IS
OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO AB FIFTY
NINETY SIX HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCE
FINAL CLEANUP. TO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED A ROOF
REMOVED E. T. S. C. AND REDUCE
COSTS. SECTION ROLL CALL FROM
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL
PASSES SEVEN. TO ZERO QUIRK MS
QUIRK SILVA AB ONE THIRTY THREE
PROPERTY TAX POSSIBLE MINUTE TO
DO PASS UP TO THE ROLL CALL.
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL'S APPROVE SEVEN TO ZERO AB
ONE THIRTY NINE EMERGENCY AND
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING ACT OF TWO
NINETEEN. DO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED LANE FOR
MANY IMPLEMENTATION ARENA.
METHODOLOGIES PROVISIONS FOR
SPECIFIED COGS SENT TO THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THE BILL PASSES SEVEN. ZERO
AB FOUR ONE FORTY THREE SHELTER
CRISIS LOCAL ORDINANCE FOR
HOMELESS SHELTERS. DO PASSED
WITH A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
EXTEND HDDS DEADLINE TO SUBMIT.
FINDINGS ON DRAFT ORDINANCES
AND TO ADD AN URGENCY BECAUSE
AND CO AUTHOR THE BILL PASSES
PASSES. SEVEN ZERO BECAUSE
RECEPTION THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO. AB.
THREE FIFTY FOUR SCHOOL
NUTRITION SPACE. CHILDREN EAT
IS A TO PASS RECEPTION ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE THREE OR TWO SO
THE BILL PASSES FIVE TO TWO.
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO AB
THREE SIXTY EIGHT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA VETERANS CEMETERY TO
DO PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO
AUTHORIZED TO LOCATIONS FOR THE
CEMETERY SITE. AND TO REQUIRE
CALVET APPROVAL WE'RE GOING TO
CALL THE ROLL. PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. EDWARD
BRADFORD AYE TO RAZA DORADO AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES. MY CASKET
MAKOWSKI AYE. THE BILL IS OUT
FIVE ZERO AB NINE FORTY SEVEN
VISUALLY IMPAIRED PUPILS
EXPANDED CORE CURRICULUM THAT
IS A TO PASS AND RECEPTION THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO IT PASSES SEVEN TO
ZERO MISTER RAMOS AB FIVE
TWENTY NINE PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS OVER TIME A TO DO
PASS. SUB TO THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE THIRTY THREE OH TWO THAT
BILLS APPROVED FIVE TO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SEVEN PEOPLE
SUICIDE PREVENTION POLICIES TO
PASS FOR THE MEMBERS FOR
AUTHORED WHICH WERE
COORDINATION THE COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH PLANS AND MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES WILL ROLL
CALL. PORTANTINO AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE LINES. THE DRIVE
BATES AYE BRADFORD. BRADFORD
I'D TO RAZA DORADO AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES. JON SNOW AYE
CASKEY MAKOWSKI AYE. THE BILL
WAS OUT SIX TO ONE. MISTER RAY
IS AN OPTION ME MS RAMOS AB SIX
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
SERVICES MENTOR AUTHORED
REQUIRE S. P. I. TO ESTABLISH A
WORKING GROUP TO IMPROVE
COORDINATION OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
SERVICES SECTION ROLE FROM
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL
PASSES SEVEN TO ZERO AB NINE
EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION IS A
DO PASS. WE'RE DOING A ROLL
CALL VOTE. PORTANTINO HI YOU
KNOW I BATES. BRADFORD BRADFORD
I TO RAZA TO ROSS SO I HILL
HILL AYE JONES JONES NO WAY
CASKEY HI MY COUNTY I. THE BILL
IS OUT FIVE TO ONE AB EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE RESOURCE FAMILY
TRAINING IT TO DO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR THE STRIKE
THE IN PERSON TRAINING
REQUIREMENT DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION AMEND TO LIMIT
TO CARE GIVERS OF CHILDREN OVER
TEN AND LIMIT TO COMMERCIAL
SEXUAL EXPLOITATION. SUB TO THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN
YOU TO THE BILL PASSES SEVEN TO
ZERO AB NINE SEVENTEEN VICTIMS
OF CRIME AMEND FOR AUTHOR TO
DEFINE A SPECIFIC TERM STRIKE
ACCESS TO POLICE REPORTS. BY
CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. PORTANTINO I WANT TO
KNOW AYE BATES. BRADFORD I TO
RAZA DORADO I HELL HILL AYE
JONES JONES NO WAY CASKEY
MAKOWSKI AYE. THE BILL WAS OUT
FIVE TO ONE A. B. FIFTEEN TEN
SEXUAL ASSAULT OTHER SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT THAT IS A TO PASS
FOR THE MEN'S FOR AUTHORED
REVIVE ONLY CLAIMS OVER TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND REQUIRE
THE CLAIMANTS ATTORNEY TO
DECLARE UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY OF THEIR GOOD FAITH
BELIEF THAT THE CLAIMS VALUE
AND OTHER URGENCY CLAUSES. AT
AN EMERGENCY CLAUSE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. I PORTANTINO AYE
BATES BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I TO RAZA TERRAZZO AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES JONS NO WAY
CASKEY HI MY COUNTY I. THE BILL
IS OUT SIX TO ONE. THREE OF US
AB SIXTEEN. MANY POSITIONS FOR
HOMELESS CHILDREN IT IS A DO
PASSED WITH A MAN'S PER AUTHOR
TO MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES SENT
TO THE ROLE FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO IT IS PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY SEVEN TO ZERO AB
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN IS INTEREST
TRACK INFRASTRUCTURE INTRA
DISTRICT TRANSFERS FOR STUDENTS
THAT ARE BULLIED TO PASS IS THE
RECOMMENDATION SUBSTITUTE RAW
FROM THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL PASSES SEVEN ZERO A. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN HIGHER
EDUCATION PROHIBITED DEBT
COLLECTION PRACTICES IT'S A DO
PASS SUB TO THE ROLE FOR MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL
PASSES SEVEN TO ZERO. MAYBE
FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT SCHOOL
PAVEMENT TO PARKS GRANT PROGRAM
IT IS A TO PASS AS AMENDED PER
AUTHOR TO MOVE THE PROGRAM
UNDER THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY AMEND TO MAKE PROGRAM
CONTINGENT UPON CORPORATION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PORTANTINO I WANT TO KNOW AYE
BATES. IT'S AYE BRADFORD
BRADFORD I DORADO TO RAZA I
HELL. HILL AYE JONES JONES NO
WAY CASKEY CASKEY AYE. THE BILL
IS OUT SIXTY ONE HOMES
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL IT IS A TO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO REMOVE
THE SIX POSITION SOLEIL
REPORTING DEADLINE TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES ACCEPTING THE
ROLE FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THE BILLS APPROVED BY
UNANIMOUS SEVEN TO ZERO VOTE
ROBERT RIVAS AB NINE THREE SIX
OIL SPILLS RESPONSE TO DO PASS.
SUB TO THE ROLE FOR MAYBE THREE
OR TO THE BILL PASSES FIVE TO
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
AB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE LOCAL
SURPLUS PUBLIC LAND AT A BASE
TO DO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO STRIKE THE CURRENT
PROVISIONS REQUIRE LOCAL
AGENCIES TEND TO BE REPORTS
SURPLUS LAND EIGHT EIGHT CD A
MENTOR CRIER AGD TO PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION TO D. G. S. FOR
INCLUSION. IN THE STATEWIDE
INVENTORIES HAVE TO THE ROLE
FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE BILL PASSES SEVEN TO ZERO
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE
FORMER HOUSING STREAMLINED
APPROVALS AND AGE TO A WORKER
PROHIBITION SUBSTANCE ADDICTION
ME TO DO PASSED WITH A MEMBERS
PER AUTHOR TO REDUCE
AFFORDABILITY COMMITMENT TO
THIRTY FIVE YEARS THAT WE
CHANGE THE DEFINITION OF
EMPLOYEE HOUSING AND MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLE FOR MAYBE THREE TO.
THOSE BROUGH FIVE TO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW MISTER
RODRIGUEZ AB. TWO SIXTY FIVE TO
NINETY FOUR ON GASSING THAT IS
UP TO THE ROOM AS A DEAL TO
PASS UP TO THE ROLE AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL PASSES
SEVEN TO ZERO AB NINE ELEVEN
REGISTRY INFORMATION THE PAST
FOR THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR
REQUIRE FEASIBILITY STUDY
RELATED. TO REPORT INSTEAD OF
DEVELOPING A PLAN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL PORTANTINO I TWENTY NO
I BATES BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE TO RAZA. DRAWS A
AYE HILL. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES BATES I'D BRADFORD
BRADFORD I DORADO DORADO AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES JONES NO
WAY CASKEY MAKOWSKI I. THE BILL
IS OUT SIX TO ONE AB TEN NINETY
THREE MS FOR FINANCIAL
CAPABILITY IN NOW ALLEN'S
ANALYSIS THAT IS A DO PASS
ACCEPTED THE ROLL CALL FROM
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL
PASSES SEVEN TWO ZERO AB ONE
ONE ONE EIGHT LOCAL PLANNING
LIVE ABILITY ISSUE FOR OLDER
ADULTS TO DO PASS. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. ADVERTISE
BRADFORD AYE TO RAZA DORADO AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES. JONES NO
WAY CASKEY MAKOVSKY I. THE BILL
IS NOW FIVE TO ONE AB THIRTEEN
OH SEVEN CAL GRANT PROGRAM
FORMULA FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY INSTITUTIONS SO
TO THE BEAU TO DP SECTION TO
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL AS A PROOF
SEVEN TO ZERO IN THE FIFTEEN
NINETY PERSONAL INCOME TAX
CREDITS QUALIFIED FIRST TIME
HOME BUYERS. IT'S A DO PASS FOR
THE MEMBERS TO MAKE THE CREDITS
OPERATIVE IN YOUR SPECIFIED IN
A TRAILER BILL IT IS A-
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FOR MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL
PASSES SEVEN TO ZERO AB SIXTEEN
FORTY FIVE DREAMER RESOURCE
LIAISONS IS A TO PASS SUB TO
THE ROLL CALL FROM THREE OH TWO
THE BILL PASSES FIVE TO TWO
WITH REPUBLICANS. VOTING NO MR
SALAS AB TWO OH THREE
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
VALLEY FEVER TO DO PASS
ACCEPTED THE ROLE FOR MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL
WAS APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY SEVEN
ZERO AB FIVE NINETY FOUR IS IT
ON ARTIFICIAL ATTEND TELOGEN TO
DO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS FOR
AUTHOR TO ENCOURAGE RATHER THAN
REQUIRE CDT. TO DESIGNATE AN
EMPLOYEE TO OVERSEE A I USE IN
STATE GOVERNMENT SUBSIDY ROLE
FROM THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL PASSES SEVEN TO ZERO AB
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN SALES AND
USE TAX EXEMPTION VEHICLE
MODIFICATIONS FOR HANDICAPPED
VETERANS IS TO DO PASSED WITH
THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO ADD
CO AUTHORS. SUB TO ROLL FROM
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL
PASSES SEVEN ZERO MISTER
SANTIAGO AB TWO CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROMISE
PROGRAM THE MEMBERS SAID CO
AUTHOR MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES
IT'S A DO PASS WITH THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND IT'S A
SUBSTITUTE ROLL CALL FROM
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO IT PASSES
SEVEN TO ZERO AB EIGHT NINETY
FOUR EXEMPT FROM CIVIL SERVICE.
MEMBERS PER TO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO PROHIBIT
A NET INCREASE IN DEPARTMENT
EXPENDITURES MENTOR REDUCE
POSITIONS TO DIRECTORS AND TWO
DEPUTY DIRECTOR SUBSTANTIVE
ROLE FOR MAYBE THREE OH TWO THE
VOTE. IS PASSED FIVE TWO UP.
THAT WAS EIGHT NINETY FOUR
RIGHT. SUB TO THE ROLL CALL
FROM AB THREE OH TWO PASSES
FIVE TO TWO WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO AB STALLED SO MANY
FIVE MENTAL HEALTH OUT THREE
EACH TEAM'S PILOT PROGRAM IS A
DO PASS SUBSTANCE TO ROLL CALL
FOR THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL PASSES. SEVEN TO ZERO AB
FORTINO FOR. REPORTING
OBLIGATIONS. MEMBER AUTHORED
REQUIRE NONPROFIT SPONSORS TO
POST DISCLOSURES ONLINE AND TO
STRIKE SECRETARY OF STATE
REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE THREE OR TO THE
BILL'S APPROVED FIVE TO TWO.
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO A.
B. FIFTEEN SIXTY THREE FALSE
REPRESENTATION TO PASS SUB TO
THE ROLL CALL FROM THREE OO TO
THE BILL PASSES FIVE. TWO TWO
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW
MISS SMITH AB FIVE FORTY THREE
SCHOOL SEXUAL HARASSMENT
THE ROLE FROM A. B. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO IT PASSES SEVEN TO
ZERO SB SIX TWENTY NINE CRIME
VICTIMS. AMENDS IT'S A NEW
PATCH FOR THE MEN'S PROPER TO
MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES SUB TO
THE ROLE FAR FROM THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO IT PASSES SEVEN TO
ZERO. A. B. NINE SIXTY SEVEN
LOCAL CONTROL AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN. IS A DO
PASS UP TO THE ROLE FOR MAYBE
THREE OR TO THE BILL PASSES
FIVE. TO TWO WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO AB TWELVE THIRTY
THREE. THE PROGRAM FOR ADVANCED
PLACEMENT EXAMS TO PASS UP TO
THE ROLE FROM A. B. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. THE BILL PASSES
SEVEN TO ZERO AB FIFTEEN OH
SEVEN CHARTER SCHOOL RESOURCE
CENTERS TO DO PASSED WITH THE
MEMONS. FOR AUTHORED A TREE
CHARTERS THAT CLOSE AND REOPEN
IS CONTINUING SCHOOLS MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. FOR
CHARTERS LOCATE ON TRAVEL LANDS
AND OTHER MEMONS TO EXEMPT
RESOURCE CENTERS MEETING
SPECIFIED CRITERIA. SUCH AS THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB THREE OH TWO
THIS BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
FIVE TO VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS.
VOTING NO. AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN UNCLAIMED PROPERTY THIS
IS A DO PASS SUB TO THE ROLE
FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO.
IT PASSES UNANIMOUSLY SEVEN TO
ZERO AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
ENROLLMENT. IT'S A DO PASS
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FOR MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL
PASSES SEVEN. TO ZERO. MR STONE
A. B. FORTY FIVE IN MAKE
MEDICAL CARE FEES IS TO DO PASS
SUB TO THE ROLE OF MAYBE THREE
OH TO THE BILL'S APPROVED FIVE
TO TWO. WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW AB. TWO FIFTY THREE REMOTE
COURT REPORTING. IT'S TO DO
PASSED SUBS. CALL VOTE
PORTANTINO FIVE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
DERISIVE DORADO AYE HILL HILL
AYE JONES JONES NOBODY CASKEY
MY COUNTY I. THE BILL IS OUT
FIVE TO ONE EIGHTY FORTY NINE
FLOOD CONTROL POWER HARO RIVER
IS A DO PASS SUB TO ROLL CALL
FROM THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO BUT
PASS A SEVEN TO ZERO AB NINE
SIXTY FIVE YOUTH OFFENDER
PAROLE HEARINGS TO PASS WITH
THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO
STRIKE THE CREDIT EARNING
PROVISIONS AND SAID SPECIFY
WHEN A PERSON'S YOUTH OFFENDER
PAROLE HEARING. MUST OCCUR SUB
TO THE ROLL CALL FROM THREE UP
TO THE BILL PASSES FIVE TO TWO
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO AB
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN INSPECTION OF
PUBLIC RECORDS TO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED A LIMIT
THE BILL TO DISCLOSE OF ALL
RECORDS AND ALLOW ONLY
EQUIPMENT THAT DOES NOT MAKE
CONTACT WITH THE RECORD
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE THIRTEEN NEED TO THE BILL
PASSES. SEVEN ZERO MR CAME AB
SIXTY ONE GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS AS A TO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR
CLARIFY THE DEFINITIONS OF
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATION STAFF AND
MAKE TACTICAL CHANGES UP TO THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE THREE OF
TWO BILLS FROM FIVE TO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW. AB
SIXTY EIGHT ON ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS TO DO PASSED SUB
TO THE ROLL CALL FOR ME THREE
OH TWO THE BILL PASSES FIVE
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW AB
SIXTY NINE EIGHTY YOU SMALL
HOMEBUILDING STANDARDS TO PASS
SUB TO THE ROLL CALL MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL
PASSES SEVEN. ZERO AB FIVE
TWELVE CULTURAL COMP CITY
ASSESSMENT PLANS TO DO PASS
WITH THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED
REQUIRE THAT HE Q. R. O. TO
CONSIDER DISPARITIES REDUCTION
TARGETS PLEASE CALL. THE ROLL.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PORTANTINO. FORTINO AYE BATES.
BRADFORD BRADFORD I DORADO.
DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES KNOWING CASKEY HI MY
CASKEY AYE. THOSE OUT FIVE TO
ONE. AB TEN SEVENTY SIX
CRIMINAL RECORDS IT'S A DO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS FOR OFTEN MAKE
SPECIFIC FOR TEN CAN A
PROVISIONS CONTINGENT UPON A
BUDGET APPROPRIATION MAKE OTHER
CHANGES MEANT TO APPLY THE
RELIEF TO PERSPECTIVE REST
RECORDS ONLY SPECIFY LIMITED
LIMITATION OF THE ARREST
RECORDS RELIEF AND LIMIT THE
TYPE OF CONVICTIONS AFFECTED
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FROM THREE
OH TO THE BILL PASSES FIVE TO
TWO OF REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY. THIRD PARTY
FOOD DELIVERY TO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED REMOVE
VEHICLE INSPECTION REQUIREMENTS
LOWER FIND TO MAKE OTHER
CLARIFYING CHANGES SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLE FOR MAYBE THREE OH TWO
THE BILL PASSES FIVE TO TWO
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX SURPLUS
LAND ACT LOCAL AGENCY LAND
INVENTORY DO PASS THE MEMBERS
FOR AUTHORED A STRUCTURE PLUS
WHEN INVENTORY DATABASE
PROVISIONS SUBSTANCE THE ROLE
FOR MAYBE THREE OR TO. THE
PASSES FIVE TO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW MAYBE
FOURTEEN NINETY THREE GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS TO
DO PASSED WITH THE MEMBERS FOR
AUTHOR TO MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES SUB TO THE ROLE A. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO BILL PASSES
SEVEN TO ZERO MR VOEPEL AB
THREE SEVENTY TWO INFINITE WORK
PROGRAM TO PASS. SUB TO THE
ROLE FROM A. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THE BILL PASSES SEVEN TO
ZERO MS WEBER AB ONE NINETY
SEVEN FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN AS
A DO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS
PROVIDE AN EXEMPTION FOR
PROGRAMS WITH FACILITY ISSUES
SUBSTANTIVE ROLE MAY BE THREE
OH TWO BILLS BEING APPROVED
FIVE TO TWO WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO AB THREE SIXTY NINE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
BIRD SALARY ADJUSTMENTS. IT IS
TO PASS WE'RE SUBSTANTIVE ROLE
FROM THREE OO TO THE BILL
PASSES FIVE TO TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO AB SIX
TWELVE CAL FOR US RESTAURANT
MEALS I DO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS
FOR AUTHORED AND A CO AUTHOR
SUBSTANTIVE ROLE FOR MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO BILL PASSES
SEVEN TO ZERO AB SEVEN A ONE
EXONERATION HOUSING COSTS MEN'S
PER AUTHORS TRY TO REQUIRED
MINIMUM DURATION OF HOUSING
ASSISTANCE AND SPECIFY SYSTEM.
SYSTEM. LIMITED TO. A SUB TO
THE ROLL CALL FROM. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL'S PROVED
SEVEN TO ZERO AB NINE FORTY TWO
CAL FRESH RESTAURANT MEALS
PROGRAM IT'S A TO PASS UP TO
THE ROLL CALL FROM THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. BILL PASSES SEVEN
TO ZERO AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN CALL CENTER PROTECTIONS
TO DO PASSED WITH A MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO GIVE THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER. AUTHORITY
PROMULGATE REGULATIONS TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CLARIFYING CHANGES
SUBSTANCE THE ROLE FOR MAYBE
THREE OH TWO. THE BILL PASSES
FIVE TO TWO WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING. NO AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN ME COLLEGE FUNDING
DETERMINATION FOR NON CREDIT
COURSES TO DO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. SUB TO THE
ROLE FROM THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE BILL PASSES SEVEN. ZERO MS
WICKS AB EIGHT THREE SIX WHILE
FIRE SMOKE CLEAN AIR CENTERS
FOR VULNERABLE POPULATIONS TO
PASS. THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED
WHICH DAMAGE THE CLEANER CENTER
PROBABLY PROGRAM AMEND TO MAKE
CONTINUE TO FIND.
APPROPRIATIONS IN THE BUDGET
SUBSIDY TO ROLL FROM THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL PASSES
SEVEN TO ZERO AB ELEVEN FIFTY
THREE MANDATED CHILD ABUSE.
PORTING EMPLOYEE TRAINING.
OTHERS AND TO PASS FROM THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES THE BILL
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO. THE BILL
PASSES SEVEN TWO ZERO AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN CAL
FRESH. TO PASS SUBS TO THE ROLE
FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE BILL. PASSES SEVEN. ZERO B.
SIXTEEN OH THREE. CALIFORNIA
VIOLENCE INTERVENTION
PREVENTION GRANT PROGRAM. TO
PASS FOR THE MEMBERS TO CHANGE
THE PARAMETERS OF THE GRANT
PROGRAM SUB TO THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THAT BILL WAS APPROVED A
UNANIMOUS SEVEN. TO ZERO. VOTE
MISTER WOOD AB THIRTY EIGHT
FIRE SAFETY HARDEN HOMES
RETROFITTED TO PASS A MEN'S PER
AUTHORED REQUIRE YES AND CAL
FIRE TO DEVELOP ALLOW FOR
MITIGATION PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
FOR HOMES HARDENING. AND TRY TO
PROVISIONS RELATING TO OUR
REVOLVING LOAN FUND PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BRADFORD
BRADFORD I DORADO RAZA AYE HILL
HILL AYE JONES. JON SNOW I
GUESS HE HIGH BY CASKEY AYE.
FIVE TO ONE AB TWO OH FOR
HOSPITAL HOSPITAL COMMUNITY
BENEFITS PLAN REPORTING. EXCEPT
TO THE ROLL CALL OUR TO DO PASS
UP TO THE ROLL CALL FROM
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE BILL
PASSES SEVEN ZERO EIGHTY TO
NINETY HEALTH PLANS AND
INSURANCE THIRD PARTY PAYMENTS
TO DO PASSED WITH THE MEMONS
PER AUTHOR TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION AND AMENDMENTS
TO MAKE CLARIFYING. CHANGES
WERE SUBS IN THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE THREE OH TWO THAT BILL
WAS APPROVED ON A FIVE TO VOTE
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING. NO AB
EIGHT TWENTY FOR PRESERVING
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE DRUGS.
THAT IS A TO PASS FOR THE
MEMBERS TO CLARIFY EXEMPTION.
PROVISIONS WE'RE GOING TO A
ROLL CALL VOTE. PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BRADFORD
BRADFORD I DORADO TERRAZZO AYE
HELL HILL AYE JONES. JONS NO
WAY CASKEY CASKEY AYE. FIVE TO
ONE EIGHTY NINE FIFTY FOUR
DENTAL THIRD PARTY NETWORK
ACCESS AS A DO PASS SUB TO THE
ROLL CALL FROM MAY BE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO PHIL PASSES SEVEN.
ZERO A. B. TEN EIGHTY EIGHT
MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY THAT IS A
TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS FOR
AUTHOR TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES. SUB TO THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE BILL'S APPROVE SEVEN TWO
ZERO AB ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. AS IN
THE PAST WITH THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHORED IN OUR BILL SCOPE AND
MAKE CHANGES TO THE DATA
EXCHANGE PROVISIONS. THAT IS A
SUB TO ROLL CALL FROM THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE BILL PASSES
SEVEN. TO ZERO MR WOULD AB SIX
FORTY TWO MEDI CAL MANAGE I'M
SORRY SIXTEEN FORTY TWO MEDIC
MEDIC COW MANAGED CARE PLANS.
TO PASS AS AMENDED FOR AUTHORED
REMOVE OUT REACH PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS TO LEAVE MEDI CAL
CAPTION RATE AND PROVISIONS TO
MAKE OTHER CHANGES SUB TO THE
ROLL CALL FROM THREE OH TWO.
THE BILL PASSES. FIVE TO TWO
WITH REPUBLICANS. VOTING NO.
OUR FINAL BILL OR IS ALLEN SCA
I'M SURE OTHERS TO I'M SORRY
ALLEN SCA ONE. PUBLIC HOUSING
IS A DO PASS WE'RE GONNA DO A
ROLL CALL VOTE. YOU KNOW I
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BRADFORD
BRADFORD I DORADO TO RAZA AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES JONES I
WIECKOWSKI HI MY CASKEY AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT SIX ZERO OUR
FINAL BILL IS MR UMBERG SB SIX
SIX FIVE ON COUNTY JAILS IS TO
DO PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE PROGRAM A PILOT AND
REQUIRE PARTICIPATING COUNTY TO
REPORT SPECIFIED INFORMATION
ROLL CALL VOTE. PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BRADFORD
FOR TIED TO RAZA TORONTO I HELD.
WELL I JONES. LIKE US HE
WIECKOWSKI AYE. THE BILL WAS
OUT FIVE ZERO ONE SPECIAL
ANNOUNCEMENT YOU MAY HAVE
NOTICED EARLIER THAT THE FALL
OF THE POST RELATED TRAINING
BILLS WERE HELD ON SUSPEND SAYS
YOU KNOW EARLIER THIS YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED A BE THREE
NINETY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WEBER WHICH ENACTED SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO THE STANDARDS FOR
THE USE OF DEADLY FORCE BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE MAJOR REFORMS
IN AB THREE NINETY TWO IS JUST
ONE STEP TOWARDS BETTER POLICE
COMMUNICATIONS AND COMMUNITY
RELATIONS IT'S INCUMBENT UPON
THE LEADERS OF THE STATE TO
MAKE SURE THAT OFFICERS CROSS
STATE ARE PROPERLY AND
EFFECTIVELY TRAINED. ON NEW
STANDARDS SO SB TWO THIRTY BY
CENTER CAP A GYRO PLANES OUT
LAYS OUT THE FRAMEWORK TO DO
THAT BUT ESTABLISHING IN
CERTIFYING TRAINING COURSES
CONSISTENT WITH THE NEW
STANDARDS WILL BE A MONUMENTAL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR POST AND WE
MUST ENSURE THAT THE COMMISSION
IS NOT DOES SO EFFECTIVELY AND
AS EXPRESSED EXPEDITIOUSLY AS
POSSIBLE WITH UNDIVIDED
ATTENTION CONSEQUENTLY THIS
DECISION OF THE COMMITTEE TO
NOT ADVANCE ANY LEGISLATION
THAT PLACES NEW
RESPONSIBILITIES OUR DUTIES ON
POST OUTSIDE OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE TO USE OF
FORCE RELATED STANDARDS SO ALL
OF THOSE POSTS RELATED BILLS.
WERE HELD WITHOUT PREJUDICE NOT
BASED ON ANYTHING TO DO WITH
THE MERITS OF THOSE BILLS JUST
WITH THE SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
THAT THE TWO NEW BILLS ARE
GONNA HAVE ON POST TRAINING SO
WE THOUGHT IT BEST TO JUST HAVE
THOSE TO PASS SIMILARLY LAST
YEAR OR LAST TIME WE HELD A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF MOTOR
VEHICLE RELATED BILLS BECAUSE
WE DIDN'T WANNA OVER BURDEN DMV
SO SAME PRINCIPLE THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT STUFF WE WANT
TO GET IT RIGHT WE DON'T WANT
TO BURDEN FILES SO THAT'S ONE
SPECIAL ANNOUNCEMENT TICKET FOR
THE AUTHORS WHO HAD POST
RELATED BILLS. THEY UNDERSTAND
WHY WE DID WHAT WE DID ALSO THE
FOLLOWING MEASURES WILL BE
CONSIDER TO YOUR BILLS AND
REMAIN ELIGIBLE FOR ACTION BY
THE COMMITTEE NEXT YEAR AB TWO
THIRTEEN BY RAY S. A. B. THREE
THREE. ONE BY MEDINA AB THREE
SEVEN SIX BY MR STONE A. B. SIX
FIVE SIX EDUARDO GARCIA. SB SIX
NINE FOUR OR WHEN AB EIGHT NINE
EIGHT WHERE X. A. B. NINE SEVEN
FIVE CALDERON AB ONE THOUSAND
ONE TING. AB ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
CARILLO A. B. FOURTEEN SIXTY
WEBER AND AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
NINE DALY. THAT INCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS THANK YOU BYE BYE